I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金西。我们一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在，我们专门为你制作了终极办公室重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女士。
Hello. Hey there. How are you? I'm good. Look at you. You got a little knit hat on. You got a little fuzzy sweater. You look so cute. I know. Well, I was very cold today.
你好。嘿，你好。你好吗？我很好。瞧瞧你。你戴着一顶针织小帽。穿着一件毛茸茸的小毛衣。你看起来太可爱了。我知道。嗯，我今天觉得好冷。
We're having a cold snap and I couldn't get warm. So I put on my little hat. My friend Alec knitted this hat for me. I wear it all the time when we go like on ski trips. I love a hand knitted hat. I am in short sleeves because I'm having a little bit of a hot flash. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, I wear it all the time when we go like on ski trips. I love a hand knitted hat. I am in short sleeves because I'm having a little bit of a hot flash. We are two very different temperatures today.
我们这里遭遇了寒流，我怎么也暖和不起来。所以我戴上了我的小帽子。我的朋友亚历克为我织了这顶帽子。我们去滑雪旅行之类的时候我总是戴着它。我超爱手工织的帽子。我穿着短袖，因为我有点潮热。哦，天哪。我们俩今天的体感温度完全不同。
We are. Also, do we sound like complete old ladies right now? This is how old ladies start their conversations with like their aches and their pains and their hot flashes. That's it. This is who we become. Well these two old gals are going to break down couples discount for you today. Pretty much. Their aches and their pains and their hot flashes. Uh-huh. That's it. This is who we become. Well, these two old gals are going to break down couples' discount for you today.
确实。还有，我们现在听起来像不像完全的老太太？老太太们就是这样开始谈话的，聊着她们的酸痛和潮热。就是这样。这就是我们现在的样子。好吧，这两位老姑娘今天要为大家剖析“情侣折扣”这一集。
That's right. It's season nine, episode 15, written by Allison Silverman and directed by Troy Miller. And here is your summary. It's Valentine's Day. And it's the last day before Andy is set to return from his very long boating adventure. Mm-hmm. It's the last day before Andy is set to return from his very long boating adventure. Erin and Pete are dating now, everybody, and she's planning to break up with Andy upon his return to the office the next day.
没错。这是第九季第十五集，由艾莉森·西尔弗曼编剧，特洛伊·米勒执导。以下是剧情梗概。今天是情人节。这也是安迪从他那漫长的划船冒险之旅归来前的最后一天。嗯哼。这是安迪结束漫长划船之旅归来前的最后一天。埃琳和皮特现在在约访了，各位，她正计划等安迪第二天回到办公室后跟他分手。
However, plot twist, Andy shows up today, and the whole office tries to keep his secret that he's been gone from David Wallace. We'll see how that goes. The rest of the folks in the office decide to couple up and take advantage of Valentine's Day discounts at a nearby mini mall. And Jim and Pam are gonna have a Valentine's Day lunch with Brian, the boom guy.
然而，剧情大反转，安迪今天就现身了，整个办公室都在努力向大卫·华莱士隐瞒他已经离开一段时间的事实。我们拭目以待结果如何。办公室里其他人决定成双成对，去附近的小型购物中心享受情人节折扣。而吉姆和帕姆将和 boom 话筒员布莱恩一起吃情人节午餐。
Whomp, whomp. Yes, this is ultimately gonna cause some friction between Jim and Pam. All right, fast fact number one, Amy Hill. Major comedy legend guest star alert, everybody. I mean, here's the thing. Amy Hill is just one of those actors that when you see her in something,
噔噔咚。是的，这最终会在吉姆和帕姆之间产生一些摩擦。好的，冷知识第一条，艾米·希尔。重大喜剧传奇客串明星警报，各位。我的意思是，情况是这样的，艾米·希尔就是那种演员，当你在某部剧中看到她时，
you're like, oh my God, I love her. Yeah. Right? She's brilliant. Brilliant. I'm gonna give you some background on her. She was born in Deadwood, South Dakota to a Japanese American mother and a Finnish-American father.
你就会想：哦天哪，我太喜欢她了。对吧？她太棒了。太棒了。我要讲讲她的背景。她出生于南达科他州的死木市，母亲是日裔美国人，父亲是芬兰裔美国人。
She started her career working with the famed Asian-American Theatre Company in San Francisco, California. And she is also a very respected performance artist. She has written and performed a number of one-woman shows. We were so lucky to have her. You have probably seen her many times on such shows as Mom, Friends, Seinfeld, All American Girl, The Hughleys, Night Court, Six Feet Under,
她的职业生涯始于加利福尼亚州旧金山著名的亚美剧团。她也是一位备受尊敬的行为艺术家。她写过并表演了许多独角戏。能邀请到她我们真是太幸运了。你可能在很多节目中多次看到过她，例如《老妈》、《老友记》、《宋飞正传》、《美利坚女儿》、《休利一家》、《夜间法院》、《六尺之下》，
Desperate Housewives, King of the Hill, Third Rock from the Sun, The Sarah Silverman Program, and we have our very own crossover connection here, Angela Kinsey. Both you and Amy Hill have appeared on the show Life in Pieces. We did. Amy was the principal and I played Ruth who worked at a pet adoption booth. I was just in one episode. Okay. Amy is an amazing character actress. She's just a legend. Her filmography is huge and I want you guys to know there's a fantastic interview
《绝望的主妇》、《山丘之王》、《歪星撞地球》、《萨拉·西尔弗曼节目》，我们这里还有属于我们自己的交叉客串联系，安吉拉·金西。你和艾米·希尔都出演过电视剧《生活碎片》。我们演过。艾米演校长，我演露丝，在宠物领养摊位工作。我只演了一集。好吧。艾米是一位出色的性格演员。她简直是个传奇。她的作品表非常长，我想让你们知道，
with her by the AV Club. And I'm going to put it in our stories because it's great. I love it. And everyone, you can now catch Amy on the new Magnum PI. Are you ready for fast fact number two? I am. I'm calling this one Jim and Pam, Valentine's Day, not their holiday. Um, I'm calling this one Jim and Pam Valentine's Day, Not Their Holiday.
《AV俱乐部》对她进行了一次精彩的采访。我把它放到我们的动态里，因为它太棒了。我太喜欢了。大家现在可以在新版《夏威夷神探》中看到艾米的身影。你们准备好听冷知识第二条了吗？准备好了。我把这个叫做吉姆和帕姆的情情人节，不属于他们的节日。
Uh, I did a review of their experiences on Valentine's Day. What? I'm leaning back. I'm getting my iced tea. This is not their day. It is not. I've divided their list into the following categories. Lousy, meh, and good. I love a category. You know I do. They have way more lousy and meh Valentine's
呃，我把这个叫做吉姆和帕姆的情人节，不属于他们的节日。呃，我回顾了他们过情人节的经历。什么？我往后靠了靠。我拿起了我的冰茶。这不是他们的节日。确实不是。我把他们的清单分成了以下几类：糟糕、一般和好。我喜欢分类。你知道的。
Days than good ones. They should stop trying to celebrate this day. Your face is very funny when you say meh. Meh. OK, here are their worst Valentine's Days. Are you ready? Season two on Valentine's Day, this is when Phyllis got a lot of gifts
他们的糟糕和一般的情人节比好的要多得多。他们应该停止尝试庆祝这个节日。你听到“一般”这个词时，表情非常搞笑。一般。好吧，以下是他们最糟糕的情人节。准备好了吗？第二季的情人节，就是菲莉丝收到很多礼物的时候，帕姆不得不应付源源不断送给菲莉丝的花。
and Pam had to manage all the flowers coming in for Phyllis. Yes. But then Roy didn't get her anything and then Jim didn't get her anything. Her friend didn't save the day. Yeah, that was a double whammy for Pam. Yes. Season eight, special project.
是的。但罗伊没给她买任何东西，吉姆也没给她买任何东西。她的朋友并没有拯救局面。是的，这对帕姆来说是双重打击。是的。第八季，特殊项目。
This is when Pam returns from her maternity leave, only to find out that Jim is now going to go to Tallahassee for a special project. That happened on Valentine's Day. OK. And now season nine, couples discount. They have lunch with Brian the Boom Guy and get in a giant fight.
这是帕姆产假归来，却发现吉姆要去塔拉哈西执行特殊项目。那发生在情人节那天。好吧。现在是第九季，情侣折扣。他们和 boom 话筒员布莱恩吃午餐，然后大吵了一架。
Terrible Valentine's Day. Terrible. Listen to their meh Valentine's Day. OK. Their season Valentine's Day. Terrible. Listen to their meh Valentine's Day. Okay. Their season four chair model. That's the day that Pam set up her landlady with Michael. That happened on Valentine's Day. Okay. Season five blood drive. Pam and Jim spent Valentine's Day with Bob Vance and Phyllis who hooked up in the bathroom. Now we could move this to the good column. I was gonna say. Because it's a funny say, I think they had a fun Valentine's Day.
糟糕的情人节。糟糕。听听他们一般的情人节。好吧。他们第四季的“椅模”。那是帕姆把她的女房东介绍给迈克尔的日子。那发生在情人节那天。好吧。第五季的献血日。帕姆和吉姆跟鲍勃·万斯和菲莉丝一起过了情人节，他们在浴室里勾搭上了。现在我们可以把这个移到“好”的那一栏。我正要这么说。因为这是一个有趣的说法，我觉得他们度过了一个有趣的情人节。
You would call that a good Valentine's Day? I didn't say good. I said fun. Like, oh my god, can you believe that happened? Kind of like something they've laughed about for years, maybe. Right. I didn't say good. That's why I said it was meh. Okay, alright.
你会把那叫做一个好的情人节吗？我没说好。我说有趣。就像，哦天哪，你能相信那居然发生了吗？有点像他们多年来一直在笑的事情，也许吧。对。我没说好。这就是为什么我说它一般。好吧，好吧。
And then in season six, the manager and the salesman, that's the day they met Joe Bennett. Meh. Meh, okay. Listen, we don't know what happened at home on those Valentine's days. We don't, because we don't know anything about their home life. We don't.
然后在第六季，《经理与推销员》，那是他们见到乔·贝内特的日子。一般。一般，好吧。听着，我们不知道他们在那些情人节里家里发生了什么。我们不知道，因为我们对他们的家庭生活一无所知。我们真的不知道。
Other than they have a clown painting and he makes salmon. They've only had one good Valentine's Day that we've seen, like truly good. It was season seven, PDA, that's when they hooked up in the closet and where we believe they conceived Philip. It's only a good Valentine's Day for Jim and Pam.
除了他们有一幅小丑画，而且他会做三文鱼。我们见过的他们唯一一个真正意义上的好情人节。那是第七季的“公开秀恩爱”，就是他们在储藏室里勾搭上那次，也是我们认为他们怀上菲利普的时候。对吉姆和帕姆来说，只有那一个是真正好的情人节。
Every other Valentine's Day at the office is either meh or horrible. So not their day. Not their holiday. No, it's not. I loved that. All right, fast fact number three, everybody. You've been waiting for it.
办公室里其他的每一个情人节要么是一般，要么是糟糕。所以这不是他们的日子。不是他们的节日。不，确实不是。我太喜欢这个了。好了，冷知识第三条，各位。你们一直在等待它。
You've been wondering when it's gonna happen. Here is your landline update. Oh, okay, let's go. On March 16th, on the front page of my Sunday New York Times, which you know I get every week, there was an article with this headline. I'd never been so excited. It said this, quote,
你们一直在想它什么时候会出现。以下是你们的固定电话更新。哦，好吧，我们开始吧。在3月16日，在我的《纽约时报》周日版的头版上，你知道我每周都会买，有一篇文章带有这样的标题。我从来没有这么兴奋过。它是这么写的，引述：
landline users remain proudly old fashioned in the digital age. This is tying back into our opening of this whole episode. This is what old people talk about. It's true. I did notice that most of the people quoted in the article were over 60. So the reason for this article is because there are phone companies that want to phase
固定电话用户在数字时代仍然保持着骄傲的老派作风。这呼应了我们这一集开头的讨论。这就是老一辈人谈论的话题。确实如此。我确实注意到文章中引用的大多数人都超过了 60 岁。所以这篇文章的原因是因为有些电话公司想要淘汰固定电话。
out the landline. The number of copper landlines, which is also known as plain old telephone service or POTS. POTS? POTS. Okay. If you have POTS, you have plain old telephone service. The number of people who have this fell by 89% over the last 20 years in California. Wow.
铜质固定电话的数量，也就是人们所知的普通老式电话服务，简称 POTS。POTS？POTS。好吧。如果你有 POTS，你就拥有普通老式电话服务。在加利福尼亚州，拥有这种服务的人数在过去 20 年里下降了 89%。哇。
I know. So here's the thing that I want to get out there to everyone. OK? This is important to me. All right. It's like pockets to me. POTS is like pockets to you? Yes.
我知道。所以我想对大家说的是这个，好吗？这对我很重要。好吧。这对我来说就像口袋一样。POTS对你来说就像口袋？是的。
OK. A landline is pockets to you? Yes. OK. A landline is not just a home phone. A true landline has to be hooked up to a copper wire. And most phone companies are phasing these out. And instead, you can have a landline. You can have a phone that goes into the wall. But they are putting them on fiber optic cable. And it's not a landline.
好吧。固定电话对你来说就是口袋？是的。好吧。固定电话不仅仅是家里的一部电话。真正的固定电话必须连接到铜线。大多数电话公司正在淘汰这些。取而代之的是，你可以拥有一个固定电话。你可以有一部插在墙上的电话。但它们把它们连接在光纤电缆上。那不是固定电话。
Not a true landline. And the reason they're doing this is because those fiber optic cables can also carry cable and internet services. So it's like they can hook everything up to that as it comes into your house. And this is what my phone company did to me without telling me. They switched my landline, quote unquote, to a fiber optic cable line, and I had to call and make them put me back on a copper line. Because power failures can take out fiber optic cables. They depend on electricity to work. So this is why your Wi-Fi goes out when your power goes out. But copper wires are self-powered and
不是真正的固定电话。他们这样做的原因是因为这些光纤电缆还可以承载有线电视和互联网服务。所以就像他们可以在它进入你家时把所有东西都连接到上面一样。这就是我的电话公司在没有通知我的情况下对我做的事情。他们把我的固定电话，也就是所谓的固定电话，换成了一条光纤电缆线路，我不得不打电话让他们把我调回铜线。因为电力故障会毁掉光纤电缆。它们依靠电力才能工作。这就是为什么当你的电力中断时，你的 Wi-Fi 会断掉。但是铜线是自带电源的，
they do not go down in the event of a power outage. I will say I loved everyone who was quoted in this article. They are sassy, they are stubborn, and they are my people. Derek Shaw, 68 of York, Pennsylvania, loves his landline. He also prefers speaking to people face to face. He's not a fan of Zoom and he listens to records. Okay. He said, quote, I've never even thought about giving up my landline and I'll go kicking and screaming when I have to. That's right. Here are some reasons not related to a zombie apocalypse where you might want a landline. I know I often talk about the zombie apocalypse as my reason for needing these services, but there's other reasons. Okay. If there's a power outage from a flood, a fire, or other natural disaster.
在断电的情况下也不会中断。我必须说，我喜欢这篇文章中被引用的所有人。他们很时髦，他们很固执，他们是我的同类。来自宾夕法尼亚州约克的 68 岁的德里克·肖喜欢他的固定电话。他也更喜欢与人面对面交流。他不是 Zoom 的粉丝，他听黑胶唱片。好吧。他说，引述：我从来没有想过放弃我的固定电话，如果有必要，我会在被逼无奈时才会放弃。没错。以下是一些与僵尸末日无关的、你可能想要固定电话的原因。我知道我经常把僵尸末日作为我需要这些服务的原因，但还有其他原因。好吧。如果洪水、火灾或其他自然灾害导致停电。
Katie Lanza, who was 37, she's from... 37, we got a youngin in there. Yeah. She's from Fort Worth, and she said that her dog chewed her cell phone. And while she was waiting to get her replacement, she got sick in the middle of the night, and she needed help, and she didn't have a phone. She had to go to her neighbor's house to use a phone. And ever since, she's had a true landline. So there you go.
37 岁的凯蒂·兰萨，她来自……37岁，我们节目里迎来了一个年轻人。是的。她来自沃思堡，她说她的狗咬了她的手机。在她等待更换手机的时候，她在半夜生病了，她需要帮助，而她没有电话。她不得不去邻居家借电话。从那以后，她就拥有了一部真正的固定电话。所以你看。
Flood, fire, natural disaster. Something happens to your cell phone. I'm not done, okay? I didn't think you were because you're holding several pieces of paper. Yeah. Francellia Jackson, 61, from Illinois said she worries about cyber attacks disrupting her self-service and that's why she has a landline. After I read this article, it compelled me to double-check with my phone company to make sure that they hadn't switched me again. And I do still have a POTS.
洪水，火灾，自然灾害。你的手机出了问题。我还没说完，好吗？我以为你没说完，因为你手里拿着好几张纸。是的，来自伊利诺伊州的 61 岁的弗兰塞莉娅·杰克逊说，她担心网络攻击会扰乱她的自助服务，这就是她拥有固定电话的原因。在我读了这篇文章之后，它促使我再次与我的电话公司核对，以确保他们没有再次帮我转换。我确实仍然有 POTS。
I do have that copper landline. Good for you. And we have the cutest little old-timey phone with the little buttons. My kids are mesmerized by it. They love to call us on our cell phones from the landline and like prank us. That's cute.
我确实有那个铜质固定电话。那很好。我们有一个最可爱的小老式电话，上面有小按钮。我的孩子们对它着迷。他们喜欢用固定电话给我们的手机打电话，就像恶作剧一样。那太可爱了。
They love it. Push button phone, old timey. There you have it everyone. Public service announcement. You might want to pots. I think it's a great idea. I'm also very curious what they wrapped the fiber optics cables in.
他们很喜欢。按键式电话，老式的。大家都有了吧。公共服务公告。你可能想要一个 pots。我觉得这是个好主意。我也很好奇他们用什么包裹光纤电缆。
Because as you know, my car wasn't working. All the computer buttons were flashing, seatbelt alert, drive train malfunction, airbag. I'm like, what's happening? Well, I have, as it turns out, massive rodent damage. They've, whatever rodent, I don't know if it was a rat, a squirrel, a mouse, whatever, has been eating away at my engine.
因为如你所知，我的车坏了。所有的电脑按钮都在闪烁，安全带警报，传动系统故障，安全气囊。我在想，怎么了？嗯，结果证明，我遭遇了大规模的啮齿动物破坏。它们，不管是什么啮齿动物，我不知道是老鼠、松鼠还是小鼠，一直在啃咬我的发动机。
And they told me that they used to wrap all the electrical stuff in your engine in like some kind of plastic or something, but now to be more earth friendly, it's wrapped in like a type of soy, and rodents love soy. So now it's a thing, rodent damage. I couldn't believe it when you called me about this
他们告诉我，他们过去常常用某种塑料之类的东西包裹发动机里的所有电气东西，但为了更环保，现在它们被包裹在某种大豆成分里，而啮齿动物喜欢大豆。所以现在这是一个常见问题，啮齿动物破坏。当你给我打电话谈到这个，
and told me that rodents had eaten your engine. Yes, thousands of dollars of damage guys, thousands of dollars of damage. I still don't have my car back, but I have now been really looking into ways you can prevent rodents from eating your car. There's like a spray, right? Yeah, I'm going to be getting that. If any of you guys have tips for rodent damage, let me know. Well, listen, this has been a very informative top of show. Sorry, we took it off. We got off on a big tangent.
并告诉我啮齿动物吃了你的发动机时，我简直不敢相信。是的，几千美元的损失，伙计们，几千美元的损失。我的车还没拿回来，但我现在真的在研究防止啮齿动物吃你车的方法。有一种喷雾，对吧？是的，我打算买那个。如果你们有什么关于啮齿动物破坏的建议，请告诉我。好吧，听着，这是一场非常信息量巨大的节目开头。抱歉，我们聊嗨了。我们扯远了。
We have learned again about landlines, and also now we're warning you, don't let rodents eat your car. Yeah, be wary of rodent damage. It can happen. On that note, why don't we take a break, and then we'll come back and let's discuss couple's discount, the worst Valentine's Day Jim and Pam have ever had.
我们再次了解了固定电话，现在我们也警告你们，不要让啮齿动物吃掉你们的车。是的，当心啮齿动物的破坏。这是会发生的。既然如此，我们为什么不休息一下，然后回来讨论“情侣折扣”，吉姆和帕姆经历过的最糟糕的情人节。
It's definitely the worst. And I have lots more from the shooting draft that wasn't in the episode to share. It was even worse than what we saw? Yes. All right, we are back and I'm going to kick things off with a fan question from Lexi H in Brockville, Ontario. Why, oh why, is there no cold open in this episode? Was it simply cut for time? Was there a filmed cold open?
这绝对是最糟糕的。而且我有很多剧本里没有播出的拍摄初稿内容要分享。比我们看到的还要糟糕吗？是的。好的，我们回来了，我将以来自安大略省布罗克维尔的莱克西·H的一个粉丝提问来开启接下来的内容。为什么，哦，为什么这一集没有开场白？是因为时间不够被剪掉了吗？有拍摄过开场白吗？
Can we see or hear the deleted scene? Angela, can you help us out? Lexi, this is a fantastic catch and you are correct. There is no cold open because the cold open for this episode was actually moved and put as the tag for moving on part two. So yes, there was a scripted cold open. It just got moved. Wow. Yes, and we will share about it in moving on part two. So yes, there was a scripted cold open. It just got moved.
我们可以看到或听到被删掉的场景吗？安吉拉，你能帮帮我们吗？莱克西，这是一个非常棒的发现，你说得对。这一集没有开场白，因为这一集的开场白实际上被移到了《继续前行（下）》的彩蛋里。所以是的，剧本里是有开场白的。只是被移位了。哇。是的，我们会在《继续前行（下）》中分享它。所以是的，剧本里是有开场白的。只是被移位了。
Wow. Yes, and we will share about it in moving on part two. Perfect. I would like to share that the title of this episode changed three times. I saw the call sheets this week and I noticed that on Monday's call sheet, this episode was called Andy's Return.
哇。是的，我们会在《继续前行（下）》中分享它。太棒了。我想分享的是，这一集的标题改了三次。我这周看了通告单，我注意到在周一的通告单上，这一集被称为《安迪的归来》。
On Tuesday's call sheet, it was called Pretending to Be a Couple. That was the clunkiest title. Finally on Wednesday, it was called Couples Discount. Yeah, I read the shooting draft again. So many good nuggets in it. But the shooting draft was called Andy's Return. This episode is going to open on Jim and Pam. They're at their desks. They're at their desks. They're working side by side. Pam is so happy that they're gonna be together
在周二的通告单上，它被称为《假装是一对情侣》。那个名字最笨拙。最后在周三，它被称为《情侣折扣》。是的，我又读了一遍拍摄初稿。里面有太多好的细节了。但拍摄初稿的名字叫《安迪的归来》。这一集将以吉姆和帕姆开场。他们在办公桌前。他们在办公桌前。他们并肩工作。帕姆太高兴了，他们可以在情人节这天
on Valentine's Day. Yes, and Jim agrees. He begged his partners to switch days, but that does mean he's gonna have to work an extra day in Philly next week. Yeah, womp, womp. I have a fun tidbit. This episode was the last episode we shot
在一起。是的，吉姆也表示同意。他求他的合伙人们调换日期，但这确实意味着他下周不得不在费城多工作一天。是的，噔噔咚。我有一个有趣的趣闻。这一集是我们圣诞假期前拍摄的最后的一集。所以片场是情人节，但后台却装饰成了圣诞节。确实如此。
before our Christmas break. So it was Valentine's Day on the set, but backstage it was decorated for Christmas. It sure was. And we both saw on the call sheets that Steve Burgess sent us that there was a Crew Secret Santa gift exchange this week. I asked Steve what all went into this gift exchange, and he said, first of all, there was a budget. You could only spend $25 on your gift. And then he said there was a questionnaire
我们俩都在史蒂夫·伯吉斯发给我们的通告单上看到，这周有一个剧组秘密圣诞老人礼物交换活动。我问史蒂夫这次礼物交换是怎么进行的，他说，首先，有一个预算。你的礼物只能花 25 美元。然后他说助理导演团队制作了一份问卷，
that the AD staff made that everyone had to fill out. Oh my gosh, that's so cool. Yeah. So that way you could get somebody a gift that would be like a good match. Yeah, that they might actually want. Yeah. Yeah. Erin and Pete now have a cute flirty moment.
每个人都必须填写。哦天哪，太酷了。是的。这样你就能给某人买一份很合拍的礼物。是的，他们可能真的想要的礼物。是的。是的。埃琳和皮特现在有一个可爱调情的时刻。
Erin wants to know if he wants to play hooky today. Yeah, Erin says she wants to have fun today because tomorrow is gonna be a nightmare because Andy's coming back from his boat trip and she's breaking up with him. So she wants to make today special. We then have a Pete talking head where he says, Erin's breaking up with Andy, but he's not too sure
埃琳想知道他今天想不想逃学。是的，埃琳说她今天想玩得开心点，因为明天会是个噩梦，因为安迪要从他的划船之旅回来了，而她要和他分手。所以她想让今天变得特别。然后我们有一个皮特的单人访谈，他说，埃琳要和安迪分手，但他不是很确定，
because Erin has told Pete, we can do whatever you'd like to do today. And that kind of reminded him of when he was a kid and his parents did that before they put his dog down. But he's not too sure because Aaron has told Pete, we can do whatever you'd like to do today. And that kind of reminded him of when he was a kid and his parents did that before they put his dog down. Yes. And then in the next scene, Aaron gets out of Frisbee and she's like, do you want to play?
因为埃琳告诉皮特，今天你想做什么我们都可以。这有点让他想起他小时候，他父母在他把狗安乐死之前也是这么对他的。但他在心里打了个问号，因为埃琳告诉皮特，今天你想做什么我们都可以。这让他想起了他小时候，父母在他带狗去安乐死之前也是这么对他的。是的。然后在下一个场景中，埃琳拿出一个飞盘，她说，你想玩吗？
Do you want to play? Lady, there was so much more to this bit. It's in the shooting draft. It's also partly in deleted scenes. It's really funny. I want to read you two of the scenes that they wrote for it. The first one is Aaron sends the frisbee flying sideways. It goes under a car.
你想玩吗？天哪，这段内容远不止于此。它在拍摄初稿里。它也部分出现在删除场景中。真的很有趣。我想读给你们听两个为它写的场景。第一个是埃琳把飞盘扔得偏离了方向。它钻到了一辆车底下。
Aaron says, oh, ham it to deli. It's under the car. We need a stick. Come on, Pete, let's find a stick. Then they're playing frisbee again and Aaron tosses the frisbee. This time it sails past Pete into the bushes. Pete runs to retrieve it. Aaron says, no no Pete, put it down. That's dirty. Don't
埃琳说：哦，天哪，它在车底下。我们需要一根棍子。来吧，皮特，我们去找根棍子。然后他们又在玩飞盘了，埃琳把飞盘扔了出去。这次它飞过皮特掉进了灌木丛里。皮特跑去把它捡回来。埃琳说：不不，皮特，放下它。那很脏。别
touch it. He looks in the bushes and pulls out a dirty sleeping bag. Pete, some homeless guy stashed his stuff back here. Aaron, oh just leave it. Leave it Pete. Leave it. Pete pulls out more stuff. Aaron says, Pete that's dirty. Leave it. Leave it. Pete pulls out more stuff. Erin says, Pete, that's dirty. Leave it. Leave it alone. You are not bringing that into the office. Leave it. I feel like they had a lot of fun with that.
碰它。他在灌木丛里看了看，拉出一个脏睡袋。皮特，某个流浪汉把他的东西藏在这后面了。埃琳，哦，随它去吧。随它去吧，皮特。随它去吧。皮特拉出更多东西。埃琳说：皮特，那很脏。随它去吧。随它去吧。皮特拉出更多东西。埃琳说：皮特，那很脏。随它去吧。别管它了。你不能把那个带进办公室。随它去吧。我觉得他们拍这段时玩得很开心。
I was really expecting that sleeping bag to somehow end up belonging to Creed. Oh, for sure. Right. That's Creed stash. Yeah, like sometimes Creed sleeps outside rather than in the ceiling or all the weird places he sleeps. Under the desk. Yeah.
我本来真的很期待那个睡袋不知怎么最后成了克里德的东西。哦，肯定的。对吧？那是克里德的藏匿处。是的，就像有时候克里德会睡在外面，而不是睡在天花板上或者他睡觉的那些奇怪的地方。桌子底下。是的。
Now we're going to get a new window into how things have been working since Andy's been gone. We see Dwight go into Andy's office and pretend like he's talking to Andy and then Andy talks back to him and then quote unquote Andy signs his expense report. Yes. Dwight has really enjoyed Andy being gone. Yeah, he says, I like pretend Andy. Kevin now has a talking head where he says,
现在我们将看到一个新窗口，了解自从安迪离开后事情是如何运作的。我们看到德怀特走进安迪的办公室，假装在和安迪说话，然后安迪跟他搭腔，然后所谓的安迪在费用报销单上签字。是的。德怀特真的很享受安迪不在的日子。是的，他说，我喜欢假装的安迪。凯文现在有一个单人访谈，他说，
you know what, Andy left a carton of milk in the fridge, which he's, I guess, been sipping on the whole time Andy's been gone. And now it's goodbye chunky lemon milk because Andy's coming back. Ugh. I know, you know, we had a mini deep dive from Shalee D. in Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania.
你知道吗，安迪在冰箱里留了一盒牛奶，我猜他自从安迪离开后就一直在喝那盒牛奶。现在我们要和有块状柠檬牛奶说再见了，因为安迪要回来了。呃。我知道，你知道的，我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡的沙莉·D的一个迷你深度解析。
Hi, Shalee, you write us every week. Shalee, you're the best. This was a lemon milk deep dive. Oh no, really? Yes, Shalee said, this scene made me wonder, is there actually a lemon flavored milk? I mean, we know that the joke is that this milk is spoiled and everything.
嗨，沙莉，你每周都给我们写信。沙莉，你太棒了。这是一次柠檬牛奶深度解析。哦不，真的吗？是的，沙莉说，这个场景让我想知道，真的有柠檬味的牛奶吗？我的意思是，我们知道这个笑话是说这牛奶变质了什么的。
But guess what? There is. Shalee said, Lifeway Kefir makes organic lemon whole milk. And Shalee would like to know if we think we would enjoy lemon milk. Are we fans of lemon flavored stuff? I love lemon flavored everything, so I would try it. I don't know if I'm going to like it everything so I would try it. I don't know if I'm gonna like it but I would try it. I tried to get my hands on some for today. Yes. Oh
但你猜怎么着？还真有。沙莉说，Lifeway Kefir 牌有一种有机柠檬全脂牛奶。沙莉想知道我们觉得我们会不会喜欢柠檬牛奶。我们是柠檬味东西的粉丝吗？我喜欢所有柠檬味的东西，所以我会尝尝看。我不知道我是不是会喜欢它，但我会尝尝看。我试着为今天弄到一些。是的。
Lord. I was not successful. It's only sold at select grocery stores, this particular brand, but I became so curious about it that now I kind of want to taste it because I also like lemon flavored things. Like would this be good in a tea? Maybe. Like a little splash of lemon milk? Maybe so. I don't know. Well in the shooting draft this Kevin talking head would have actually started a series of everyone
哦天哪。我没有成功。只有某些精选杂货店才卖这个特定品牌，但我对它太好奇了，以至于我现在有点想尝尝它，因为我也喜欢柠檬味的东西。这放在茶里会好喝吗？也许吧。加一点柠檬牛奶？也许吧。我不知道。嗯，在拍摄初稿中，凯文的这段单人访谈实际上会开启一系列每个人
sharing their feelings about Andy coming back. It's also in deleted scenes. I want you to hear it. Nellie, what's wrong with your face? Andy's coming back tomorrow. Ugh. I guess I'll be back to one lunch and one nap a day. I feel like I'm in the service again. Oh yeah. With Andy away, it's been a lot of fun. In fact our desk clump has kind of become fun central. We get a little crazy.
分享对安迪回来的感受的对话。它也在删除场景中。我想让你们听听。内莉，你的脸怎么了？安迪明天就要回来了。呃。我想我又要回到一天吃一顿饭睡一个午觉的日子了。我觉得我又在当兵了。哦，是的。安迪不在的时候，可好玩了。事实上，我们的办公桌区有点成了快乐中心。我们玩得有点疯狂。
Well I might be alone here but I'm happy Andy's coming back. You can never have too many ding-dongs on the dance floor. You know what I'm saying? What a great line. That is a mug. Meredith is a mug. You can't have too many ding-dongs on the dance floor. You know what I'm saying? I love it.
嗯，也许我一个人这么想，但我很高兴安迪回来。舞池里永远不会嫌“叮咚”太多。你知道我在说什么吗？多棒的一句台词。梅雷迪思真是一绝。舞池里永远不会嫌“叮咚”太多。你知道我在说什么吗？我太喜欢了。
Oh, man. Well, they are commiserating about Andy's return, and Nellie thinks they should all have one last boss-free day of fun. This is when Phyllis announces, you know the mini mall is having a couple's discount for Valentine's Day. Maybe they should all couple up, get some discounts. Angela, this is an amazing line read from you. You say that you get your toes detailed at the nail place in the mini mall and quote, they use a watch repair kit. But it's the way you say it.
哦，天哪。好吧，他们正在为安迪的归来发牢骚，内莉认为他们都应该度过最后一个没有老板的快乐日。这时菲莉丝宣布，你知道小型购物中心情人节有情侣折扣吗。也许他们都应该成双成对，去拿一些折扣。安吉拉，你这一句台词读得太绝了。你说你去小型购物中心的指甲店修脚趾甲，而且引述：“他们用的是手表修理工具。”但你的语气太神了。
Like I'm proud. So proud. So proud. But I mean, later you see the reception Angela gets at the nail salon. It's amazing. I love it. She's like a queen there.
就好像我很自豪。超级自豪。超级自豪。但我的意思是，后来你看到安吉拉在美甲沙龙得到的待遇了。太棒了。我太喜欢了。她在那里就像个女王一样。
She is. Well, everyone's gonna do it. They're gonna couple up. Clark is gonna be Nellie's pretend boyfriend and I guess Phyllis and Stanley. Oscar asked Daryl to be Nellie's pretend boyfriend and I guess, Phyllis and Stanley. Oscar asked Daryl to be his fake boyfriend. But Angela, who do you couple up with? I think she just goes on her own.
她确实是。好吧，每个人都要去。他们要成双成对。克拉克要当内莉的假男朋友，我猜还有菲莉丝和斯坦利。奥斯卡让达里尔当他的假男友。但是安吉拉，你和谁成双成对？我想她自己一个人去了。
I guess she doesn't want the discount. She probably doesn't care. Maybe she goes there enough she already gets a discount. Maybe so. Okay. Jim and Pam are in the kitchen. They're eating Valentine's chocolates. They're really destroying the box. It's said, I want you to know in the shooting draft, that they have dec in the kitchen. They're eating Valentine's chocolates. They're really destroying the box.
我猜她不想要那个折扣。她可能不在乎。也许她去得够多了，她已经有折扣了。也许吧。好吧。吉姆和帕姆在厨房里。他们在吃情人节巧克力。他们真的在大快朵颐。话说，我想让你们知道，在拍摄初稿里，他们在厨房里，
It's said, I want you to know in the shooting draft, that they have decimated the box, even though they were cheap and didn't taste good. Like something like that. I enjoyed filming the scene. Pam shares that she made a reservation for State Street Grill. And Jim was like, oh my gosh, how romantic. And then she's like, oh, we'll be meeting Brian and Alyssa. And he says less romantic. Way less. I want you to know that I love eating chocolates. I love eating these kinds of little chocolates.
把那盒巧克力给吃得精光，尽管它们很便宜而且不好吃。大概是这样。我很享受拍摄这个场景。帕姆分享说她在州街烧烤店订了位子。吉姆就说，哦天哪，太浪漫了。然后她说，哦，我们要去见布莱恩和艾莉莎。他说，没那么浪漫了。差远了。我想让你们知道我喜欢吃巧克力。我喜欢吃这种小巧克力。
My favorite is Sea's chocolate, the dark chocolate raspberry cream. Oh. Do you like chocolates? Do you have a favorite? I love chocolates. I particularly love these box of chocolates. Like, you know, at Christmas we get them and Valentine's. The kids get very excited to see, even though there's a guide on the back, they like to surprise.
我最喜欢的是喜诗糖果的黑巧克力树莓奶油味。哦。你喜欢巧克力吗？你有最喜欢的吗？我喜欢巧克力。我特别喜欢这种盒装巧克力。就像，你知道，圣诞节我们收到它们，还有情人节。孩子们看到包装盒后面有指南就会非常兴奋，虽然背面有指南，但他们喜欢惊喜。
So there's often half-eaten ones for the reject ones. But yeah, I love chocolates. My favorite is the sea salt dark chocolate with caramel. And I like to put mine in the fridge and they're cold. Well, I wanted to find out what is the best boxed chocolate. Oh, okay. The New York Times did a ranking and and here's what they said. Quote, over the years, we've enlisted food experts and staffers to evaluate 36 brands of chocolate in taste tests.
所以经常有被吃了一半的不想要的口味。但是，是的，我喜欢巧克力。我最喜欢的是海盐黑巧克力配焦糖。我喜欢把它放进冰箱里冰镇着吃。嗯，我想找找看哪种盒装巧克力是最好的。哦，好吧。《纽约时报》做过一个排名，他们是这么说的。引述：多年来，我们招募了食品专家和工作人员，在盲测中评估了 36 个品牌的巧克力。
We found that Rekuti's flavors, craftsmanship, and packaging are nothing short of sophisticated. I've never had Rekuti's. Have you? I have not. Their top pick was Rekuti's Confections Black Box. You get 16 chocolates for $52 or $3.25 per chocolate. So I bought us some. Did you?
我们发现 Rekuti 巧克力的风味、工艺和包装绝对称得上精致。我从来没吃过 Rekuti 的。你吃过吗？我没有。他们的首选是 Rekuti 糖果黑盒。你花 52 美元可以买到 16 颗巧克力，合每颗 3.25 美元。所以我给我们买了一些。是吗？
I sure did. Would you like to taste what the New York Times thinks are the best chocolates today? Hell yeah. Let me get them out. Okay, here they are. They're so pretty. I can smell them. Okay, lady, there's a little guide here.
我当然买了。你想尝尝《纽约时报》认为是当今最好的巧克力吗？当然想。我把它拿出来。好吧，它们在这儿。太漂亮了。我都能闻到香味了。好吧，女士，这里有个小指南。
I'm looking to see, oh, they have recommendations for how to taste the chocolate. It says- That is fancy if it's telling you how to eat them. It says, we recommend our truffles be tasted at room temperature. Check. This encourages the full character of the flavors to emerge. Still, spring water between confections helps cleanse your taste palette. Fancy. Very fancy. All right. Do you want to just dig in, or do you want me to tell you where the caramel ones are?
我来看看，哦，它们有关于如何品尝巧克力的建议。上面写着——如果它告诉你怎么吃，那可就太高级了。上面写着：我们建议我们的松露巧克力在室温下品尝。核对完毕。这有助于全面激发风味特征。不过，在糖果之间喝点矿泉水有助于清洁味蕾。高级。非常高级。好了。你是想直接开吃，还是想让我告诉你焦糖味的在哪里？
No, I want you to find me a caramel. OK. The one that has their name on it is a burnt caramel. And then there's also a rose caramel. Ooh. I don't know what I'm eating, but I am liking it. Oh, I love candied orange peel. I'm doing the candy orange peel.
不，我想让你帮我找一颗焦糖味的。好吧。带有他们名字的那一颗是焦糖味的。然后还有一个玫瑰焦糖味的。哦。我不知道我在吃什么，但我很喜欢。哦，我喜欢糖渍橙皮。我在吃糖渍橙皮。
I thought that sounded good, too. Will you put that in half for me? Mm-hmm. I want some of that. Mm. Mm, that's delicious. That is good. Mm-hmm.
我觉得那个听起来也不错。你能帮我把它掰成两半吗？嗯哼。我也想吃那个。嗯。嗯，太好吃了。真不错。嗯哼。
Oh. Ding, ding, ding, winner, winner. Wow. It's so yummy. Very decadent. All right, we can close our box of chocolates. We have extra for you guys, Cassie and Jordan. That's right. What a treat we can close our box of chocolates. We have extra for you guys, Cassie and Jordan. That's right. What a treat, lady, that you brought chocolates. You know,
哦。中中中，赢家，赢家。哇。太好吃了。非常浓郁。好了，我们可以把巧克力盒合上了。我们有多余的给你们，卡西和乔丹。没错。女士，你带了巧克力来，真是一场大快朵颐。你知道，
recently I was touring a botanical garden and they had the cocoa plant and I learned all about like chocolate in the process. It was fascinating. I know you left me like a seven-minute message about it. I know! I want to go. Well, it's all people our age on the tour, just so you know. I'm not surprised! Well, after Jim and Pam ate their chocolates, Jim has a talking head where he says he's really looking forward to seeing Brian. He's a great guy. They've become close to him and his wife, you know, and he knows that he got fired for
我最近去参观了一个植物园，那里有可可植物，我在过程中了解了所有关于巧克力的知识。太迷人了。我知道你给我留了一条七分钟的语音留言讲这个。我懂的！我也想去。好吧，去参观的都是我们这个年纪的人，仅此而已。我一点也不奇怪！好吧，在吉姆和帕姆吃完巧克力后，吉姆做了一个单人访谈，他说他真的很期待见到布莱恩。他是个好人。他们和他的妻子关系变得很近，你知道的，而且他知道布莱恩因为
protecting Pam, and he's like, you know him, he's a good guy. Well, I think this talking head was from a candy bag alt because it was not the scripted talking head. Okay, this interests me because I found this talking head curious. So the scripted talking head was, well, you guys know Brian. Brian is a great guy. Pam and I got pretty close with him and his wife, Alyssa, over the years.
保护帕姆而被解雇了，他就想，了解他的人都知道他是个好人。嗯，我觉得这个单人访谈来自一个废弃的糖果袋场景，因为它不是剧本里的单人访谈。好吧，这引起了我的兴趣，因为我觉得这个单人访谈很奇怪。所以剧本里的单人访谈是，好吧，你们都知道布莱恩。布莱恩是个好人。这些年来，帕姆和我跟他和他的妻子艾莉莎关系挺近的。
Brian probably would have been in our wedding if the documentary didn't have strict rules about who could be a groomsman. I also used that as an excuse with my cousin, Mark. But with Brian, it's actually true. Wait, what? That's the scripted Jim talking head, but it really portrays Brian as being a close friend
如果纪录片没有关于谁能当伴郎的严格规定，布莱恩可能已经成了我们的伴郎了。我也拿这个当借口对付我的表弟马克。但对布莱恩来说，这其实是真的。等等，什么？那是吉姆在剧本里的单人访谈，但它确实把布莱恩描绘成了一个亲密的朋友，
if Jim would have asked him to be a groomsman. So the reason he couldn't be a groomsman was because the documentary crew... Had strict rules, I think, about breaking the fourth wall. Right. Being part of people's lives. Because they would have had to explain who this person was. Yeah.
如果吉姆开口的话，他就会让他当伴郎。所以他不能当伴郎的原因是因为纪录片摄制组……我想，对于打破第四堵墙有严格的规定。对。成为人们生活的一部分。因为他们不得不解释这个人是谁。是的。
Did Brian boom their wedding? Do you think Brian was there? I don't know, but isn't that interesting? That is interesting. All right, we're gonna go to the nail salon now. The technicians are making such a fuss over Angela. Baby foot ladies here. Baby foot lady.
布莱恩给他们的婚礼收音了吗？你觉得布莱恩当时在那儿吗？我不知道，但这难道不有趣吗？这很有趣。好吧，我们现在要去美甲沙龙了。美甲师们对安吉拉大惊小怪的。婴儿脚女士来了。婴儿脚女士。
We got a fan question from Sarah M. in Harrisburg, Pennsylvania. Does Angela really have teeny tiny feet or just like average small? No, I have teeny tiny feet. It's true. I wear a kid size three. That is bonkers. I know. I know. I got so excited when I was pregnant because everyone tells you you go up a foot size. Mm-hmm.
我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州哈里斯堡的莎拉·M的粉丝提问。安吉拉真的有极小的脚还是只是平均水平的小脚？不，我真的有极小的脚。这是真的。我穿童鞋三号。太疯狂了。我知道。我知道。我怀孕时兴奋极了，因为每个人都告诉你孕期脚会变大一码。嗯哼。
Right? And I was like, oh my gosh, this is going to be amazing. No, didn't change my foot size at all. Well, my experience with your tiny feet, Angela, was during our book launch in New York and we were going to go beyond Seth Meyers. And you realized as you were getting ready that you had left your gold high heels back in LA. And you needed shoes. Yeah, because all I had were sneakers or flip-flops. And then I had one pair of black shoes, but they didn't go, this was like a spring dress.
对吧？然后我想，哦天哪，这太棒了。不，我的脚码一点也没变。好吧，安吉拉，我对你小脚的经历是在我们在纽约举行新书发布会期间，我们要去塞斯·梅 Meyers 的节目。你准备出门时才意识到你把金色高跟鞋忘在洛杉矶了。你需要鞋子。是的，因为我只有运动鞋或人字拖。然后我有一双黑色的鞋，但它们不搭，这是一件春装。
Yes. And so thus began this search for shoes, gold shoes, small enough for your feet, that still looked good with your outfit. And was it Stuart Weitzman? Well, yeah, because I know, because I've had to get fancy shoes before and Stuart Weitzman has really small shoes
是的。于是就开始了寻找鞋子的过程，金色的鞋子，要小到适合你的脚，还要跟你的衣服搭。是斯图尔特·韦茨曼吗？嗯，是的，因为我知道，因为我以前买过高档鞋，斯图尔特·韦茨曼有非常小的鞋子，
for ladies with tiny feet. So that was really the first place we looked and thank goodness they had a pair and they sent them over. They were amazing. I remember that. I remember it so clearly. But they only had like two pair.
适合脚小的女士。所以那真的是我们找的第一个地方，谢天谢地他们有一双，他们把它送了过来。太棒了。我记得。我记得太清楚了。但他们只有大约两双。
And so I'm on the phone with the salesperson at Stuart Weitzman, and he was wonderful. He was taking pictures and texting them to me. They were great, and we ultimately got me a pair of shoes. They sort of flew in. Like, you arrived with sneakers in your dress, and then the shoes like met you there, right? Arrived, yeah. Yes.
所以我在电话里跟斯图尔特·韦茨曼的销售人员沟通，他太棒了。他拍了照片并用短信发给我。他们太棒了，我们最终帮我弄到了一双鞋。它们算是飞过来的。就像，你穿着裙子踩着运动鞋到了那儿，然后鞋子就在那儿和你汇合了，对吧？到了，是的。是的。
And they are fantastic. I love them. And now they are one of my favorite pair of fancy heels. Well, Sarah, there you have it. She has really tiny feet. We also got a fan question from Clara D in Germany who said, can we get a location breakdown for the nail salon, please? Yes, we can.
而且它们太棒了。我太喜欢它们了。现在它们是我最喜欢的高档高跟鞋之一。好吧，莎拉，就是这样。她真的有很小的脚。我们还收到了来自德国的克拉拉·D的粉丝提问，她说，能给我们提供一份美甲沙龙的拍摄地明细吗？是的，可以。
Thanks to Steve Burgess, we know that this place was actually called The Nail Luxury and it was located in a mini mall in Santa Clarita, California. And according to the call sheet, we had three actors and seven real manicurists playing the salon workers. Well, why don't we take a break? Because when we come back, I have lots of stuff about this episode in my digital clutter. I love it. Can we eat another chocolate on the break? You know it.
多亏了史蒂夫·伯吉斯，我们知道这个地方实际上叫“美甲奢华（The Nail Luxury）”，它位于加利福尼亚州圣克拉里塔的一个小型购物中心里。根据通告单，我们有三名演员和七名真正的美甲师在剧中扮演美甲店员工。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下呢？因为当我们回来时，我的数字杂乱文件夹里有很多关于这一集的资料。太棒了。我们在休息时能再吃一块巧克力吗？你懂的。
We are back and I tried more chocolate while you used the restroom, Angela. I found the rose caramel. Did you? No. I only ate half the restroom, Angela. I found the rose caramel. I only ate half of it. I want some of the rose caramel. You don't. I don't? I don't think you do. Oh my God.
我们回来了，安吉拉，你在洗手间的时候我吃了更多的巧克力。我找到了玫瑰焦糖味的。是吗？没有。安吉拉，我只吃了一半洗手间……我找到了玫瑰焦糖味的。我只吃了一半。我想吃玫瑰焦糖味的。你不想。我不想？我想你并不想。哦天哪。
Where is it? It's that pink one. So I'm so sorry, fancy box of chocolates. But as I go deeper, you're too fancy for me. A lot of the flavors are like... Oh, I think that's delicious. Oh, you like it? A lot of the flavors are...
它在哪儿？就是那个粉红色的。所以，非常抱歉，精美的盒装巧克力。但随着我越吃越深，你们对我也太高级了。很多味道就像……哦，我觉得这个很好吃。哦，你喜欢？很多味道……
It's strong. Like star anise, lavender. I just, I don't need my chocolates to taste like herbs and perfumes. You know what I'm saying? Mm-hmm. I mean, you liked it. I liked it. I just want my C's chocolate back now.
味道很重。比如八角，薰衣草。我只是觉得，我不需要我的巧克力尝起来像草本植物和香水。你知道我在说什么吗？嗯哼。我的意思是，你喜欢。我喜欢。我只是现在想要回我的喜诗糖果。
I just want my dark chocolate raspberry cream. Sorry. Sorry, fancy chocolates. You're great and you're fancy. But I think you can just eat one. Now I, I don't know. Sorry. Anyway, back at the nail salon, Nellie and Clark
我只是想要我的黑巧克力树莓奶油。抱歉。抱歉，高档巧克力。你们很棒也很高级。但我看你只能吃一块。现在我，我不知道。抱歉。不管怎样，回到美甲沙龙，内莉和克拉克
are getting their manicures. And Nellie's manicurist says if Clark takes off his glasses, he kind of looks like a pretty girl. And Nellie finds this hilarious. But Clark gets mad, and he decides to share, you know what? We're not really in a relationship. We're going to pay full price.
正在做美甲。内莉的美甲师说，如果克拉克摘下眼镜，他看起来有点像个漂亮的女孩。内莉觉得这太搞笑了。但克拉克生气了，他决定说出来，你知道吗？我们其实不是情侣关系。我们要付全价。
Nellie's like, turns out I can't even be in a pretend relationship. Nellie, come on. Come on, Nellie. Oscar and Darryl now arrive and they ask for two foot massages and the woman at the front desk says, no, two men can't be a couple. Well, Darryl now grabs Oscar's hand and says, you know what, we are madly in love with two disposable incomes and no kids and they'll be taking their business elsewhere. They storm out. Yeah. We got a fan question from Soyun J in South Korea
内莉说：原来我都谈不上一段假恋爱。内莉，拜托。拜托，内莉。奥斯卡和达里尔现在到了，他们要求做两个足部按摩，前台的那位女士说，不，两个男人不能成一对。好吧，达里尔现在拉住奥斯卡的手说，你知道吗，我们疯狂相爱，拥有两份可支配收入却没有孩子，他们会把生意带到别处去。他们气冲冲地走了。是的。我们收到了来自韩国的 Soyun J 的粉丝提问，
who said, in case anyone wonders, the young female worker at the nail salon who defended Oscar and Daryl to the shop owner said, it's okay, they are in that relationship. And she spoke perfect Korean with a perfect Korean accent. Well, that's nice to hear. I have to say I thought everyone in the nail salon was excellent and especially now knowing that like seven of the people were just actual manicurists. I thought all the casting was great. Let's give a shout out to Angela Shin who played one of the manicurists
她说，如果有人好奇的话，美甲沙龙里那个为奥斯卡和达里尔向店老板辩护的年轻女员工说，没关系，他们就是那种关系。而且她说着一口带完美韩国口音的流利韩语。好吧，听到这个真好。我必须说，我觉得美甲沙龙里的每个人都表现得很出色，尤其是现在知道了其中有七个人实际上是真正的美甲师。我觉得所有选角都很棒。让我们向扮演美甲师之一的安吉拉·申致意，
and also to Julia Cho. Julia Cho is an actress and she's also an incredible playwright. You know, the theater nerd in me loves this. In March 2020, she was awarded a very prestigious prize for drama. It's the Wyndham Campbell Literature Prize for Drama. And she also recently appeared in Greg Daniels' show Upload. Oh my gosh. And also, of course, Amy Hill. Are you ready now for the things I found in my digital clutter? Yes.
也要向朱莉娅·赵致意。朱莉娅·赵是一位演员，她也是一位出色的剧作家。你知道的，我体内的戏剧书呆子太爱这个了。2020年3月，她被授予了一项非常声望的戏剧奖。它是温德姆·坎贝尔文学奖戏剧奖。她最近还出演了格雷格·丹尼尔斯的剧集《上载新生》。哦天哪。当然还有艾米·希尔。你们准备好听我在数字杂乱文件夹里找到的东西了吗？准备好了。
All right. Here we go. Per the call sheets, we started filming this episode on December 17, 2012. So I went back into my digital clutter. What was happening this week? Here are some of the emails that I had with our production office and one that I had with you, lady. Oh.
好的。我们开始吧。根据通告单，我们于 2012 年 12 月 17 日开始拍摄这一集。所以我翻看了我的数字杂乱文件夹。这周发生了什么？以下是我与制作办公室的一些邮件，还有一封我和你之间的邮件，女士。哦。
First of all, I was still getting lots of emails from people who came to my Yankee Swap Christmas party. Aw. That was on December 8. Secondly, I had emails with Joya from NBC Digital because I guess I did a tour of the whole office set for NBC.com showing all of our actual Christmas decorations, like within our different departments,
首先，我仍然收到许多参加我的白色大象圣诞派对的人发来的邮件。啊。那是 12 月 8 日。其次，我和来自 NBC 数字频道的乔亚有邮件往来，因为我猜我为 NBC.com 做了一次整个办公室布景的参观，展示了我们所有的实际圣诞装饰，就像在我们不同部门内部的那种，
not pretend Christmas are real Christmas. I remember this. And I have two photos I can share in our stories from that day where I did the tour for NBC.com. Next is an email from Greg Daniels' office. His assistant wrote me and said, Hi Angela, the writing staff was hoping to meet with you tomorrow to discuss your character's arc in the final episodes.
不是假圣诞节，是真正的圣诞节。我记得这个。我拍了两张照片可以在我们的动态里分享，那是那天我为 NBC.com 做参观时拍的。接下来是来自格雷格·丹尼尔斯办公室的一封邮件。他的助理写信给我说：嗨，安吉拉，编剧团队希望能明天跟你开个会，讨论你这个角色在最终集里的剧情走向。
Will you be available tomorrow at 11am to meet with them? Oh my gosh, this is when they started the interviews. They interviewed every single member of the cast to find out what you thought would be the perfect ending for your character. Is that the coolest thing? It's the coolest thing. It meant so much to us.
你明天早上 11 点有空和他们开会吗？哦天哪，这就是他们开始访谈的时候。他们采访了演员阵容中的每一个人，以了解你认为对你的角色来说完美的结局是什么。这不是最酷的事吗？这是最酷的事。这对我们意义重大。
Well, in this email chain, mine was scheduled for December 19th at 5 p.m. Wow. Mm-hmm. Do you remember doing it? I do, actually. I remember them asking me what were my hopes and dreams for my character, if there was one last thing that she could do, where I thought she would sort of end the series at in her story arc. And I told them I thought that Angela should end up with
在这个邮件串里，我的被安排在 12 月 19 日下午 5 点。哇。嗯哼。你还记得做过这事吗？其实我还记得。我记得他们问我对我角色的希望和梦想是什么，如果她能做最后一件事情，我以为她的故事线会在哪里结束。我告诉他们，我认为安吉拉应该最终和
Dwight. Yes, 100%. And I hope that that relationship reconciled itself. Amazing. Third email was to you subject title OMG all caps! Oh leaning in. Mm-hmm. Then when you open up the email it said, Lady I am going to co-host Carson Daly's New Year's Eve show. Oh my gosh I remember when you did that. You wrote back, OMG!
德怀特在一起。是的，百分之百。我希望那段关系能重修旧好。太棒了。第三封邮件是给你的，主题是“天哪全大写！”哦，身体前倾了。嗯哼。然后当你打开邮件时，上面写着：女士，我要去联合主持卡森·戴利的跨年节目了。哦天哪，我记得你做过那个。你回信说：天哪！
That is amazing! Will you be outside the whole time? Tell me everything at lunch! Here's the thing, even when we were younger, I was still worried about the weather. It's cold! It is! And I was always cold back then.
太棒了！你要一直在外面呆着吗？午饭时把一切都告诉我！事情是这样的，哪怕在我们更年轻的时候，我还是担心天气。太冷了！确实！我那时候也总是觉得冷。
So that was a legitimate immediate concern for me as well. I just know every year that I watch those guys outside, I wonder how cold they are. I think about them at the Macy's Thanksgiving Day Parade. I think about them on New Year's Eve. I was so excited to get some insider info on how cold it actually is doing that. Angela, tell everyone. Well, here's the thing. Anyone you see that's on a platform, like you know how like you have the New Year's Eve show and they're on the main platform? Yes. And then there's people kind of out in the street
所以这对我也来说是一个合理的直接担忧。我只知道每年我看到那些人在室外时，我都在想他们有多冷。我想象他们在梅西感恩节大游行上的样子。我想象他们在跨年夜的样子。能得到一些关于做这个节目到底有多冷的内幕消息，我太兴奋了。安吉拉，告诉大家吧。好吧，情况是这样的。你看到的任何站在高台上的，就像你知道跨年夜节目那种人们站在主高台上的？是的。然后还有一些人在街上
and on the ground and around. The people on the platform have it best. It's still cold, but they have these tubes like by their feet that you can't see. It's off camera that pump in heat. All right, so yeah, your face is getting a little cold, but your bottom half is at least warm. But anyone you see that's doing the man on the street bits,
地面上和周围。站在高台上的那些人情况最好。虽然还是很冷，但他们的脚边有你看不见的暖气管。那是镜头拍不到的地方，里面吹着热风。好吧，所以是的，你的脸可能会有点冷，但你的下半身至少是暖和的。但是任何你看到在做街头采访的，
they're freezing their ass off. That was me. So the whole night I'm doing man on the street bits, there was one point where like, I remember I was like, I'm not sure if my words sound correct, because I can't really move my lips, because I was so cold. You're so cold. So at the end of the night,
他们都冻得屁股冰凉。那个人就是我。所以整个晚上我都在做街头采访，有一次，我记得我当时在想，我不确定我的话说得对不对，因为我的嘴唇真的动不了，因为我太冷了。你太冷了。所以在当晚结束时，
I joined Carson Daly on the platform and I was like, son of a bitch, it is so warm up here. What the hell? I had no idea that they had tubes of heat on the platform. Okay, lastly, the whole entire cast got an email from the production office titled, Sign a Palooza. Oh, we had a Sign a Palooza before we left? Yep, and I looked, it was also in the call sheet. Starting on Tuesday, we'll be tackling Sign a Palooza. Get ready. All right, here's what Sign a Palooza was, everyone.
我加入了高台上的卡森·戴利，我说，他妈的，上面怎么这么暖和。搞什么鬼？我根本不知道高台上还有暖气管。好吧，最后，整个剧组都收到了来自制作办公室的一封邮件，标题是“签名狂欢”。哦，我们在离开之前还有一场签名狂欢？是的，我看了，通告单上也有。从星期二开始，我们将全力投入签名狂欢。准备好吧。好的，大家，这就是签名狂欢。
They would take our lunch tables back in the back, and about half of them would be covered with scripts, posters. DVD boxes. Yes, and there would be Sharpies out and you had to go down the table and you had to sign every item. I need to put the size of the table in context and why it was called Sinopaluza. This lunch area fed 300 people. people. So this lunch table, it was actually three tables that were like half the size of the sound stage. And there would be items all the way down it. And you would start at one end, and you would make it as far as you could make it
他们会把后面的午餐桌搬出来，其中大约一半的桌子上会摆满剧本、海报。DVD 盒。是的，桌上会放着记号笔，你必须沿着桌子走，在每件物品上签名。我需要交代一下桌子的尺寸以及为什么它被称为“签名狂欢”。这个午餐区为 300 人提供餐饮。所以这个午餐桌，实际上是三张桌子拼起来的，大约有摄影棚一半那么大。上面会一路摆满物品。你从一头开始，能签多远就签多远
between a scene, and then they would mark where you made it to. Okay, Angela made it through the first half of posters. So the next time she's got to start right here. Yes. And you would tackle it and it took a week. It would take all week because you could only do it in starts and stops. Oh my gosh, Sinopalooza. Sinopalooza, yeah. And that's everything from my digital clutter for this week. That was a treasure trove. My goodness. That was really a trip down memory lane and I think gave a lot of insight into some of
两个场景之间，然后他们会标记你拍到了哪里。好吧，安吉拉拍完了第一半的海报。所以下次她得从这里开始。是的。然后你会接着干，这花了一个星期。这得花上一整周，因为你只能断断续续地做。哦天哪，Sinopalooza。Sinopalooza，是的。这就是我这周数字杂物清理的全部内容。那真是一个宝库。天哪。那真是一次重温旧梦的旅程，我认为它让我对一些
the stuff that happened behind the scenes. Thank you, Angela. Well now, Pam and Jim are going to arrive to their restaurant. Brian is sitting at a table for four. He has an empty seat next to him. Yep. They ask, where is Alyssa? And that is when Brian says, oh, yeah, we're splitting up. I do have a bulls**t word to play. What is it? Lady.
幕后发生的事情有了很多深入的了解。谢谢你，安吉拉。好了，现在，帕姆和吉姆要到达他们的餐厅了。布莱恩正坐在一张四人桌旁。他旁边有一个空座位。是的。他们问，阿丽莎在哪里？然后布莱恩就说了，哦，对了，我们要分开了。我确实有个废话词要玩。是什么？女士。
What? I call bulls**t on Pam inviting Brian and Alyssa to Valentine's lunch. Why? Because, like, her husband is working in another city. This is so special that they got to be together. Don't have Brian and Alyssa at lunch. What if it happened this way, where Brian reached out and was like, we'd love to take
什么？我觉得帕姆邀请布莱恩和阿丽莎去吃情人节午餐简直是胡扯。为什么？因为，你看，她丈夫在另一个城市工作。他们好不容易能聚在一起，这是多么特别的事啊。别让布莱恩和阿丽莎也来吃午餐啊。如果事情是这样的呢：布莱恩主动联系他们，说，我们很想请
you guys to lunch. Like, you know, it sounds like they used to get together. Yeah. Remember, he was going to be in Jim's wedding party. Jim's not around a lot. Would you want to go to lunch on this one day that Jim is in town? Let's do a couple's lunch. And then the idea was maybe Jim and Pam were going to have a romantic evening
你们俩吃午饭。就像，你知道的，听起来他们以前经常聚在一起。对。记住，他本来是要当吉姆的伴郎的。吉姆不常在身边。你愿意在吉姆在城的这唯一一天去吃午饭吗？咱们来个情侣午餐吧。然后原本的想法可能是吉姆和帕姆要度过一个浪漫的夜晚
together, even though they seem to have no plans for that because they're terrible at Valentine's day. I mean, I guess, but I feel like... So it's not like Pam reached out. It's like he reached out. Okay, fine. If he reached out and then I guess she felt bad, but still. Yes.
在一起，尽管他们似乎根本没有这个计划，因为他们过情人节实在太逊了。我的意思是，我猜是这样，但我觉得……所以这根本不是帕姆主动联系的。感觉是他主动联系的。好吧，好吧。如果他是主动联系的，然后我猜她会觉得不好意思，但还是……是的。
Okay. But here's the bull**** card that I have to play, although it tracks with how Jim and Pam are communicating lately, which is if I got a text from someone or if I had this idea, I would speak to my partner before committing. Right, you would not commit to plans without being like, hey, I know you're only here for one day this week. Yeah. It's Valentine's Day,
好吧。但我要打出这张荒谬牌，尽管这跟吉姆和帕姆最近的沟通方式倒挺符合的，那就是如果我收到某人的短信或者有了这个想法，我在做出承诺之前一定会先跟我的伴侣商量。对的，你不会在没说“嘿，我知道你这周只待一天”的情况下就答应下来。是的。今天是情人节，
you move things around so you could be here. Brian reached out, him and Alyssa wanna have lunch. And then Jim would have probably been like, oh no, let's not, let's just have the day for us. Yeah. If we get a break at lunch, let's go home and have sex because the kids are at daycare. Uh-huh. And you know we're not going to tonight because we're going to be too tired.
你把事情调开就是为了能待在这里。布莱恩联系了他们，他和阿丽莎想吃个午饭。然后吉姆可能就会说，哦不，别去了，咱们就把这一天留给我们自己吧。对。如果我们中午有空闲，我们就回家爱爱，因为孩子们都在日托中心。嗯哼。而且你知道我们晚上不会去了，因为我们会太累的。
So it's a very specific example. Very specific. Well, listen, if you want to know this restaurant location, it was Marston's on New Hall Ranch Road. It's still there. And it was recognized by Zagat as the number one place for breakfast in LA. And it was named the best breakfast in California by the Food Network magazine. I've always called it Zagat. It's Zagat? It's Zagat? It's Zagat.
所以这是一个非常具体的例子。非常具体。好吧，听着，如果你想知道这家餐厅的位置，它就是新霍尔牧场路的玛斯顿餐厅。它现在还在。它被《Zagat》评为洛杉矶排名第一的吃早餐的地方。它还被《美食杂志》评为加州最佳早餐。我一直管它叫扎加特（Zagat）。是扎加特（Zagat）吗？是扎加特（Zagat）？是扎加特（Zagat）。
I never knew that. It is hard for me to say it correctly, because I thought it was Zagat. Yeah. And we called it Zagat forever. Yeah. But it's apparently Zagat. Zagat.
我以前从不知道。我很难把它读对，因为我一直以为它是扎加特（Zagat）。对。而且我们以前一直叫它扎加特（Zagat）。对。但它显然是扎加特（Zagat）。扎加特（Zagat）。
Dwight is back in Andy's office, signing off on more paperwork as, quote, Fake Andy, when the real Andy appears behind him. I have a call sheet tidbit for this scene, Angela. Let's hear it. We shot this scene on Monday, and the back of every call sheet has a section called daily notes. This is a little spot on the call sheet
德怀特回到了安迪的办公室，以“假安迪”的身份签署更多文件，这时真正的安迪出现在他身后。安吉拉，我关于这个场景有一个通告单的花絮。说来听听。我们在周一拍摄了这个场景，每个通告单的背面都有一个叫做“每日备注”的部分。这是通告单上的一个小地方，
that includes notes for costumes, hair, makeup, props, sound. And under props in the daily notes for this scene, it said this, props note. Andy's satchel, Andy's stacked up mail, sales order to sign, pen, and then in parentheses multiples. And I was like, what happens to the pen? Why do they need multiples? I'll tell you why. Because Rainn Wilson was using it. That's right. Rainn Wilson loved options. He liked lots of choices. This is why I called
其中包括服装、发型、化妆、道具、音响的备注。在这个场景的每日备注的道具栏下，是这样写的，道具备注：安迪的斜挎包、安迪成堆的信件、待签的销售订单、钢笔，然后在括号里写着“多个”。当时我就想，这支笔怎么了？为什么需要多个？我来告诉你为什么。因为雷恩·威尔逊在用它。没错。雷恩·威尔逊喜欢有备选。他喜欢很多选择。这就是为什么我叫他
him Carrot Top, because he always needed his box of different tricks. I have no doubt that Rainn wanted to pick the pin that Dwight would be using. I wondered if it was because perhaps he might end up throwing it or doing something with it and they had to have more. No, I think it just meant that Rain Rain either wanted to click it or twist it. Right. Yes. Something.
胡萝卜头，因为他总是需要他那箱不同的把戏。毫无疑问，雷恩想挑选德怀特要用的那支笔。我曾纳闷是不是因为他最后可能会扔掉它或者对它做什么，所以他们必须准备更多。不，我觉得这只是意味着雷恩要么想按它，要么想扭它。对。是的。某种东西。
Multiples. Well, the hair and makeup note was this, Andy is tanned, unkempt as scripted, scraggly beard, unkempt hair, long dirty fingernails. The costume note was, Andy is unkempt as scripted, a Gaia Berra shirt, Sansa belt, slacks and woven loafers. I love Sansa belt.
多个。好吧，发型和化妆的备注是这样的：安迪晒黑了，剧本要求的不修边幅，参差不齐的胡须，凌乱的头发，长而脏的指甲。服装备注是：安迪按剧本要求不修边幅，穿着盖亚·贝拉衬衫、无腰带裤、休闲裤和编织乐福鞋。我喜欢无腰带裤。
It's one of my favorite terms. What is it? Sansa belt, no belt. Oh, Sansa belt. I thought it was a kind of belt. My friend's dad used to always wear pants that were Sansa belt. He's very funny comedian and he did an improv
这是我最喜欢的术语之一。那是什么？无腰带裤，没有皮带。哦，无腰带裤。我还以为是一种皮带呢。我朋友的爸爸以前总是穿无腰带裤。他是一个非常搞笑的喜剧演员，他做过一次即兴
Monologue one time about his name is Mike Buhnen. He did an improv monologue one time about his dad's Sansa belt pants I'll never forget it Well, the Dunder Mifflin crew now returned from their mini mall excursion to find Andy waiting for them Andy has so many classic like pun phrases in this episode. Oh my gosh. Here's a good one. Cancel my order from Zappos because the loafers have arrived. I mean, who does he think he is calling anyone a loafer? I know. Oscar says, hey, we thought you were coming back tomorrow. And then Andy says, no,
独白，主题是他叫迈克·布嫩。他做过一次即兴独白，讲的是他爸爸的无腰带裤，我永远不会忘记。好吧，邓德米夫林的员工现在结束了他们的迷你商场远足，回来发现安迪在等他们。安迪在这集中有好多经典的双关语短语。哦天哪。这里有一个不错的：取消我从Zappos下的订单，因为乐福鞋已经到了。我的天，他以为他是谁啊，竟然叫别人“懒汉（乐福鞋）”？我知道。奥斯卡说，嘿，我们以为你明天才回来呢。然后安迪说，不，
I came back early. It's a romantic Valentine's Day surprise for Erin. I did think it was really funny when he tried to run up to hug her and she's trying to give him just a high five. This is when Dwight says, hey, maybe you should put on a tie because David Wallace is going to be here in an hour. And Andy's like, oh, yeah, that's actually why I came back. I mean, and also to surprise
我提前回来了。这是给艾琳的一个浪漫的情人节惊喜。当他试图跑过去拥抱她而她只想跟他击掌时，我确实觉得超级搞笑。这就是德怀特说的时候，嘿，也许你应该系条领带，因为大卫·华莱士一个小时后就要来了。然后安迪就说，哦，对，其实我就是为此回来的。我的意思是，也是为了给
Erin. Andy. This is when Clark is like, why are you looking forward to this meeting with David Wallace? Isn't Wallace just going to like yell at you because you've been gone for three months? And then everyone's like, wait, David Wallace knew you were gone, right? And this is when Andy shares that actually he kept in touch with David Wallace. He emailed gone, right? And this is when Andy Scherz said actually he kept in touch with David Wallace. He emailed him all the time. He would get high-speed internet at this cafe. Erin has a talking head where she says he only emailed me four times. Yeah. That stings. Andy notices that Pam and Jim are gone. He has another snark remark about it.
艾琳一个惊喜。安迪。这就是克拉克问的时候，你为什么这么期待跟大卫·华莱士的这次会面？难道华莱士不会因为你离开三个月而冲你大吼大叫吗？然后大家都说，等等，大卫·华莱士知道你离开了，对吧？然后安迪分享说其实他一直跟大卫·华莱士保持联系。他发邮件了离开了，对吧？然后安迪分享说其实他一直跟大卫·华莱士保持联系。他经常发邮件给他。他在这个咖啡馆能连上高速上网。艾琳有个单人访谈，说他只给她发过四次邮件。好吧。这可真扎心。安迪发现帕姆和吉姆不在。他对此又发表了一句讽刺的评论。
And Oscar is like, I find it curious that you're concerned about people's absence from work. This is a great Oscar snark. Thank you, Oscar. Back at the restaurant, Brian is now sharing kind of about how him and Alyssa just drifted apart. And he said something I thought was great, which is he said, it's when they stopped fighting
奥斯卡则说，我觉得很有意思，你竟然关心别人有没有旷工。这真是一句精彩的奥斯卡式讽刺。谢谢你，奥斯卡。回到餐厅，布莱恩现在正讲着他和阿丽莎是如何渐行渐远的。他说了一句我觉得很棒的话，那就是他说，
that he knew it was over. Yeah, and he gets really emotional. He kind of starts crying. And he says, Ugh, Pam, we have to stop breaking down in front of each other. And Jim's like, what? And then he says,
当他们停止争吵时，他就知道一切都结束了。是的，而且他变得非常情绪化。他开始哭了。他说，呃，帕姆，我们得停止在彼此面前崩溃了。吉姆就说，什么？然后他说，
At least my crying won't get you fired. And Jim's like, wah, wah, wah. Pam was crying. What? I thought, what? Well, here's my bull****** card for Brian. What is it? He knew that Jim didn't know. Mm-hmm.
至少我的哭泣不会让你被解雇。吉姆就说，哇，哇，哇。帕姆刚才哭了？什么？我想，什么？好吧，这是我对布莱恩的“胡扯”牌。是什么？他知道吉姆并不知道。嗯哼。
I know what you're doing, Brian, and stop it. Ooh. Angela's not a fan. Yeah, you're trying to drive a wedge here. You're trying to find an intimate moment with Pam. In front of Jim, not cool. Not cool. This is when you're allowed to turn on Brian, everyone.
我知道你在干什么，布莱恩，住手吧。噢。安吉拉可不是他的粉丝。对，你想在这儿挑拨离间。你想在帕姆身上寻找一个亲密的时刻。在吉姆面前，这太不酷了。太不酷了。这时候，大家就可以开始讨厌布莱恩了。
Yeah, I think. Listen, at nine minutes and 35 seconds, I need to talk about the woman over Brian's shoulder. Through this whole emotional discussion, there is a woman over Brian's shoulder who full on puts her fork into her food, lifts it up to her mouth. What is it? What is she lifting up? Nothing. There's nothing on her fork. And then she mimes eating nothing off her fork. Nothing. Oh my gosh, I cannot wait to go check that out. It's crazy. So then I was like, did they not give these people real food?
对，我觉得。听着，在9分35秒的时候，我得谈谈布莱恩肩膀后面的那个女人。在整个情感讨论的过程中，布莱恩身后有一个女人，她把叉子扎进食物里，送进嘴里。那是什么？她举起的是什么？什么都没有。她的叉子上什么都没有。然后她假装从空叉子上吃东西。什么都没有。哦天哪，我等不及要去看看了。太疯狂了。然后我就想，他们难道没给这些人真正的食物吗？
Was she forced to do this? But then, if you look at the woman over Pam's shoulder, she puts food on her fork and eats it. I think that lady just didn't want to eat the prop food. I think she didn't want it. And I was like, good for you. Well, remember how I said that there was more Jim and Pam stuff in the script? Yeah.
她是被迫这么做的吗？但然后，如果你看帕姆身后的那个女人，她把食物放在叉子上吃掉了。我觉得那位女士只是不想吃道具食物罢了。我觉得她不想吃。当时我就想，做得好。好吧，还记得我说过剧本里有更多吉姆和帕姆的内容吗？对。
There was more here. There's also more later in the script. Yeah. There was more here. There's also more later in the parking lot. We'll get to it. OK. But here's how the scripted scene read in the shooting draft. OK, so the scene at lunch would have continued, like Brian is still sitting there?
这里还有更多。剧本后面也有更多。对。这里还有更多。停车场里后面还有更多。我们待会儿会讲到。好吧。但拍摄初稿里的剧本场景是这样的。好吧，所以午餐的场景会继续，就像布莱恩还在那儿坐着？
Oh, yeah. OK. Oh, man. And you know what? I'm glad they didn't include it, because I think people would have lost their minds. I do not remember this. All right.
哦，是的。好吧。哦，天哪。你知道吗？我很高兴他们没把这拍进去，因为我觉得大家会疯掉的。我不记得这个了。好吧。
In the shooting draft, it read like this. At least my crying won't get you fired. Jim says crying. And then Brian would have gone on to say, and it says in parentheses, Brian thinking he's funny says, and neither of you is trying to hug me. So maybe I should have kept my hands to myself, huh? Then Jim says, where were your hands? Then Jim looks to Pam. Pam sighs, knowing they are about to get into it. Wow. Yeah. Wow. Uh-huh. Probably good that they didn't keep that in. Good trim.
在拍摄初稿里，它是这么写的：至少我的哭泣不会让你被解雇。吉姆说“哭泣”。然后布莱恩会接着说——括号里写着：布莱恩觉得自己很搞笑，说——而且你们俩谁也没有试着拥抱我。所以也许我应该管好自己的手，对吧？然后吉姆说，你的手放哪儿了？然后吉姆看着帕姆。帕姆叹了口气，知道他们又要吵起来了。哇。是的。哇。嗯哼。没把这段保留下来大概是件好事。剪得好。
Probably good that they didn't keep that in. Good trim. Well, we're going to leave Jim and Pam in their awkward moment and go back to Dunder Mifflin. We're going to go to Andy's office where he's coming down on Dwight for not running the Scranton White Pages account details by Andy before offering such a low price point. And so he's like, I'm sorry, I'm going to need to call the white pages. And white's like, stop it. What are you talking about? Andy calls Jan. Yeah. And basically, she's like, I cannot believe you're going to call me and ask for
没把这段保留下来大概是件好事。剪得好。好吧，我们要把吉姆和帕姆留在他们的尴尬时刻，回到邓德米夫林。我们要去安迪的办公室，他正在责备德怀特没有在向安迪提供如此低的价格之前，把斯克兰顿白页广告账户的细节跟安迪商量。所以他就像，我很抱歉，我得给白页打电话了。德怀特就说，住手。你在说什么呢。安迪给简打电话。对。基本上，她说，我简直不敢相信你会在我们已经达成这个费率之后，还打电话来要求
more money after we've already agreed to this rate. And I have a clause where I can back out and I'm going to. Yeah, she says, have Angela send me the final invoice. Click. We had a fan question from Martha B. in Malta who said, I love Jan's scene in this episode. Melora really brings the character to life even through just a telephone conversation. Is this the last time the character of Jan appears?
更多的钱。我有一个可以退出的条款，而且我打算这么做。对，她说，让安吉拉把最后发票发给我。挂断。我们收到了来自马耳他的玛莎·B.的粉丝提问，她说，我喜欢这一集里简的场景。梅洛拉把这个角色演活了，哪怕只是通过电话交流。这是简这个角色的最后一次出场吗？
It is, Martha. Oh yeah, it is. That was the last time we hear Jan's voice. Mm-hmm. Aw. This is the beginning of goodbyes. It is. Well, Andy is now going to approach Angela to get his paychecks. She gives him the checks for the last 12 Fridays, but the scene was a little longer in the shooting draft and there was a bit that didn't make it in that I think is really funny
是的，玛莎。哦，是的，确实是。那是我们最后一次听到简的声音。嗯哼。啊。这是告别的开始。确实是。好吧，安迪现在要去找安吉拉拿他的薪水支票了。她给了他过去12个周五的支票，但拍摄初稿里的场景要长一些，里面有一小段没能播出来，我觉得真的非常搞笑，
and I want to share it with you. Okay. Angela says, yes, as you know, we hand out paychecks on Fridays, but you haven't been here for 12 Fridays. Andy says, sounds like a Nakapella name. And then he announces to the bullpen, now give a warm welcome to the 12 Fridays.
我想分享给你。好吧。安吉拉说，是的，如你所知，我们在周五发放薪水，但你已经连续12个周五没来了。安迪说，听起来像个无伴奏合唱团的名字。然后他向办公大分区宣布，现在，让我们热烈欢迎“十二个周五”。
And he makes his own applause sound. Angela sits with silent rage. And then the scene would have continued as scripted. And it said in the notes, when Andy strides off, he leaves the bullpen in a fury. I absolutely loved this scene. I have a big circle around it. I thought you and Oscar were so funny. I don't know. There was just something about this one that just totally got me. I have a big circle around it. I thought you and Oscar were so funny. I don't know.
然后他自己配了鼓掌声。安吉拉默默地坐在那里，怒火中烧。然后场景就会按剧本继续。备注里写着：安迪大步流星地走开时，把办公大分区留在一片愤怒之中。我太喜欢这个场景了。我给它画了个大圈。我觉得你和奥斯卡太搞笑了。我不知道。这个场景里就是有什么东西完全戳中了我的笑点。我给它画了个大圈。我觉得你和奥斯卡太搞笑了。我不知道。
There was just something about this one that just totally got me. I loved it too. I loved, I love anytime Angela and Oscar are on the same page. Yes, I think that's what it is. I like it when you guys agree. Yeah. Now everyone is lunching or snacking in the break room
这个场景里就是有什么东西完全戳中了我的笑点。我也很喜欢。我喜欢，我喜欢任何安吉拉和奥斯卡意见一致的时候。是的，我想就是因为这个。我喜欢你们俩意见一致的时候。对。现在大家都在休息室吃午饭或吃点心，
and they're all talking about how annoyed they are that Andy has gotten away with this. Yeah. Guess what Clark is eating? He's having Jim John's baby carrots. Baby carrots for Clark. Dwight is gonna suggest one of us should tell Wallace that he hasn't been here, but nobody wants to do it. Nobody wants to be the one to like rat out Andy, I guess. Yeah, and Dwight says, I'd like to rat out Andy. Unfortunately, I have a bit of a boy who cried wolf dynamic with David Wallace, except instead of a boy, I am a man, and instead of a wolf, I cried genetically engineered monster wolf.
他们都在讨论安迪竟然能逃过这一劫，这让他们多么恼火。对。你猜克拉克在吃什么？他在吃吉米·约翰的迷你胡萝卜。克拉克的迷你胡萝卜。德怀特建议说，我们中应该有一个人去告诉华莱士他根本没来过这儿，但没人愿意这么做。我想没人愿意当那个去出卖安迪的人。对，德怀特说，我很想出卖安迪。不幸的是，我在大卫·华莱士面前有点像“狼来了”的故事里的那个男孩，只不过我不是男孩，我是个男人，而狼也不是狼，我喊的是基因改造的怪物狼。
So Dwight can't do it. Dwight can't do it. Well, Andy's going to come in the break room now. And there's one section of this conversation that made me laugh so hard. It is Jake Lacey when Meredith is going on and on where she's talking about how like, there are many things you can call me, floozy, alky, Einstein.
所以德怀特不能这么做。德怀特不能这么做。好吧，安迪现在要走进休息室了。这段对话里有一部分把我逗得哈哈大笑。那是杰克·莱西，当时梅迪斯喋喋不休地说着，讲到有很多词可以用来形容她，比如放荡的女人、酒鬼、爱因斯坦。
Vomit mop. Floor meat. Flesh hoover, but never a narc. I love when Jake is like, why does no one stop her? Why does no one stop her? It's so good. It's really funny. This moment in the scene also drove home for me, something that I wanted for a long time.
呕吐拖把。地板肉。肉体吸尘器，但绝不是告密者。我好喜欢杰克说“为什么没人阻止她？”的时候。为什么没人阻止她？太棒了。真的超级搞笑。这一幕也让我深深体会到了一点，这是我一直以来都挺想要的一件事。
I'm a fan of the show, Abbott Elementary, and I have always wanted them to have Kate Flannery come on and play Melissa's sister. Melissa is like the brassy teacher on Abbott Elementary. And I don't know why. And the thing is, is like, brassy teacher on Abbott Elementary. And I don't know why. And the thing is, is like she has a sister, but she's played by someone else. But she needs another sister played by Kate Flannery.
我是情景喜剧《小学风云》的粉丝，我一直希望凯特·弗兰纳里能去客串，扮演梅丽莎的姐姐。梅丽莎就像是《小学风云》里那个大大咧咧的老师。我不知道为什么。而且关键是，她是《小学风云》里大大咧咧的老师。我不知道为什么。而且关键是，她其实有个姐姐，但由别人扮演。不过她需要另一个由凯特·弗兰纳里扮演的姐姐。
This is my feeling. You heard it here, Abbott Elementary producers. I don't know why, but I just feel like she's in this world. Actually, what would be funny is if Meredith, specifically played by Kate Flannery, is somehow related to that family. She's in this world. Actually, what would be funny is if Meredith, specifically played by Kate Flannery, is somehow related to that family. I don't know if we can do that crossover. Erin is now just going to suggest that they let
这就是我的感觉。你们在这听到了，小学的制片人们。我不知道为什么，但我就是觉得她属于这个世界。其实，搞笑的是，如果梅迪斯——特指由凯特·弗兰纳里扮演的梅迪斯——跟那个家庭有什么亲戚关系就好了。她属于这个世界。其实，搞笑的是，如果梅迪斯——特指由凯特·弗兰纳里扮演的梅迪斯——跟那个家庭有什么亲戚关系就好了。我不知道我们能不能做那种交叉串戏。艾琳现在打算建议大家让
Andy get himself in trouble. I mean, look at how he looks. Wallace is going to take one look at him and know that something is off. And that's when Andy emerges, freshly shaven and suited up, and orders everyone back to work. We had a fan question from Katie G. in Iowa who said, I've always been curious about Andy's who's that girl, who's that girl, it's Andy moment. Who came up with that idea? And did you need
安迪自己惹上麻烦。我是说，看看他现在的样子。华莱士只要看他一眼，就知道出问题了。就在这时，安迪走了出来，刮了胡子，穿好西装，命令大家回去工作。我们收到了来自爱荷华州的凯蒂·G.的粉丝提问，她说，我一直对安迪那段“那是谁家的女孩，那是谁家的女孩，是安迪”的时刻很好奇。是谁想出这个主意的？你们需要
approval from Zooey Deschanel or anyone at New Girl to use the theme song? Well, Katie, it was scripted, and Steve Burgess said, no, we did not need any permissions, but we did have to clear and pay for the song, just like any other song we used, and it was $12,000, which he said is fairly inexpensive. Well, there was a whole runner of Andy cleaning himself up. It's in the shooting draft and in the deleted scenes. I'm gonna play part of it,
得到佐伊·丹斯切尔或《杰茜驾到》剧组任何人的批准才能使用这首主题曲吗？好吧，凯蒂，这是剧本里写好的，史蒂夫·伯吉斯说，不，我们不需要任何许可，但我们必须像使用我们用过的任何其他歌曲一样，清除版权并支付费用，费用是12,000美元，他说这相对来说不算贵。好吧，安迪收拾自己的全过程其实挺长的。它在拍摄初稿和删减片段里都有。我要放一部分出来，
and then I'm gonna read you some of it. But first, let's start with this clip. Okay. Well, I wanted to show off my sweet Caribbean-y look to the whole office, but David Wallace probably wants me looking a little more professional-ish. So, time to say adios to the halitose.
然后读给你们听。但首先，让我们从这段剪辑开始。好吧。嗯，我想向整个办公室展示我那甜美的加勒比风造型，但大卫·华莱士可能希望我看起来更职业一点。所以，是时候跟口臭（halitose）说再见了。
Interesting. Yeah, I feel like there was a writer pod just on all of the phrases that Andy says in this whole cleaning himself up bit. Kareba Andy, profesh magesh. Then he goes on to say, gotta give a little trim to the Rin Tin Chin. And he holds up a comb. Then he says, gotta tame the Loch Ness monster, dreadlock monster that is. Then he holds up cologne and he says, a quick cologne-oscopy from my doctor, Sylvester Cologne. Yo Adrian, how do I smell? What is happening? Yeah, there were more, but those were the best ones. Have we talked about how, like, obsessive pun making is one of the signs of narcissism? Yes, I think we have.
有意思。对，我觉得光是安迪在收拾自己这段里说的那堆自创词，编剧们就开了一个专属创作会。加勒比安迪（Kar-Andy），职业派（profesh magesh）。然后他接着说，得给我的“丁丁下巴（Rin Tin Chin）”修剪一下。然后他举起一把梳子。接着他说，得驯服尼斯湖水怪，也就是“Dreadlock（脏辫）水怪”。然后他举起古龙水说，来一次我的医生——西尔维斯特·古龙（Sylvester Cologne）带来的“古龙水结肠镜检查（cologne-oscopy）”。嘿，阿德里安，我闻起来怎么样？这都在搞什么？对，还有更多，但这些是最好的。我们讨论过吗，比如，痴迷于说双关语是自恋的征兆之一？对，我想我们讨论过。
Okay, that's what that made me think of. Oh, boy, then I just saw the next scene. Here it is, everybody. I know. Pam and Jim in the parking lot, they're coming back from work. Yeah. She's like, you're obviously mad. Do you want to tell me what you're mad about?
好吧，这就是让我想到的原因。哦，天哪，然后我刚看到了下一个场景。大家看，就是这个。我知道。帕姆和吉姆在停车场，他们下班回来了。对。她说，你显然很生气。你想告诉我你在生什么气吗？
And he says, you know, I think it's weird that you didn't mention this big intimate detail that you and Brian shared that you cried in front of him. Yeah, but he doesn't say it as nice as that Angela. No, I know. He's like, oh my God. I just, Jim, you're upset. You're upset about Pam withholding things from you. Really?
他说，你知道，我觉得很奇怪，这么大的亲密细节——你和布莱恩分享了你曾在她面前哭过——你竟然没提。对，但他可没说得这么委婉，安吉拉。不，我知道。他就像，哦，天哪。我只是觉得，吉姆，你在心烦。你在生帕姆对你有所隐瞒的气。真的吗？
You took a whole job and spent their savings before you told Pam. You just like completely like backed her into a corner. Her only choice was to accept this decision that she got to play no part in that completely upended her family, right? Why does everyone hate Pam in this storyline when it is Jim who is so incredibly self-righteous? Well, also he's insecure.
你一声不吭就接了份工作，花光了他们的积蓄，然后才告诉帕姆。你简直是把她逼进了死胡同。她唯一的选择就是接受这个她根本没有参与决定的事，而这彻底打乱了她的家庭，对吧？为什么每个人在这个剧情线里都讨厌帕姆，明明是吉姆如此不可理喻地自以为是？好吧，而且他很没有安全感。
So it's his ego. He got embarrassed. He was embarrassed that he didn't know this detail about his wife in front of another man, that she cried, and then his embarrassment and insecurity flipped to anger. SONIA DARA GERMES Oh, that was a really good analysis, Ant. It's true. Well, he says he feels like a chump for knowing less about his marriage than the sound guy. Now, it's no longer Brian, my friend, who was almost a groomsman. It's the sound guy. SONIA DARA GERMES Right.
所以这是他的虚荣心在作祟。他觉得尴尬。当着另一个男人的面，他为自己不知道妻子身上的这个细节（她哭了）感到尴尬，然后他的尴尬和不安全感就转化成了愤怒。索尼娅·达拉·杰梅斯 哦，那真的是个很好的分析，安特。确实如此。好吧，他说，相比于声音师，他对自己婚姻的了解却更少，这让他觉得自己像个傻瓜。现在，不再是“我的朋友布莱恩、差点当上伴郎的人”了。直接成了“声音师”。索尼娅·达拉·杰梅斯 对的。
SONIA DARA GERMES Pam is like, well, I didn't want to stress you out. You're always talking about how stressed you are. And then he says, you know what? I probably don't have a right to be mad since, you know, I wasn't there. Andy is now going to hold a meeting in the conference room. He's going to try to get caught up on the last three months. Yeah, he has something written on the whiteboard.
索尼娅·达拉·杰梅斯 帕姆说，嗯，我不想让你压力太大。你总是说自己压力多大。然后他说，你知道吗？我大概没有资格生气，因为，你知道，我当时不在场。安迪现在要在会议室开会了。他要试图赶上过去三个月的进度。对，他在白板上写了些东西。
It's like, what's been going on? Yeah. It's super literal. Yeah, he has something written on the whiteboard. It's like, what's been going on? Yeah. It's super literal. Yeah, exactly. And this is when Dwight realizes they can mess with him. Yeah, Wallace comes in, Andy tries to say, oh, we're doing our weekly round table. David's like, I don't wanna interrupt.
就像，最近都在忙什么呢？对。这太字面化了。对，他在白板上写了些东西。就像，最近都在忙什么呢？对。这太字面化了。对，完全是。就在这时，德怀特意识到他们可以捉弄他了。对，华莱士进来了，安迪试图说，哦，我们在开每周圆桌会议。大卫说，我不想打扰你们。
I couldn't be happier with the numbers for the last three months. I'm just gonna go down to the warehouse because we have to talk about that guy we let go. And he leaves and then Andy's like, what, why did we let someone go? Yeah, who did we let go? Well, this is when the light bulb goes off for Dwight.
我对过去三个月的数字不能再满意了。我这就去仓库，因为我们得谈谈我们解雇的那个人。然后他走了，安迪就说，什么，我们为什么解雇人？对，我们解雇谁了？好吧，就在这时，德怀特灵光一闪。
And he says, you know, the guy that lit the whole warehouse on fire. Everyone else catches on pretty quickly. Phyllis says, oh yeah, and then we started selling balloons. And then Clark chimes in and says, yeah, and Cathy Ireland is gonna be our official spokesperson. Yeah, spokes babe for Dunder Mifflin. She's gonna be topless on the European billboard.
他说，你知道的，就是把整个仓库点着的那个人。其他人很快就反应过来了。菲莉丝说，哦对，然后我们开始卖气球了。然后克拉克插话道，对，凯茜·爱尔兰将成为我们的官方代言人。对，邓德米夫林的代言宝贝。她将在欧洲的巨型广告牌上裸露上身。
Everyone set your DVRs for 16 minutes and 35 seconds. Angela, you are very upset that Cathy Ireland will be topless on the European billboards. The look, you are very upset that Cathy Ireland will be topless on the European billboards. The look, you are horrified. You can't believe this news. It's not in the script. I think I just chose to react that way. So funny.
大家把DVR调到16分35秒。安吉拉，你对凯茜·爱尔兰将在欧洲广告牌上裸露上身感到非常生气。那个表情，你对凯茜·爱尔兰将在欧洲广告牌上裸露上身感到非常生气。那个表情，你吓坏了。你简直不敢相信这个消息。剧本里根本没有。我想我当时只是选择那样做出反应。太搞笑了。
You know, we also got a very, very funny fan catch from Alanya M. in South Carolina who said, not a question, but a wardrobe catch. Did you all notice that Kevin, Dwight, and David Wallace are all dressed almost identically? Their characters are so different, but they're all wearing a greenish-blue shirt, and it fits them all so well. You know what, I did not notice this, but I went back to look, I took a photo, it's very nice. I completely agree. It's very nice. It is agree. It's very nice. It is.
你知道的，我们还收到了一个非常非常搞笑的来自南卡罗来纳州的阿兰亚·M.的粉丝发现，她说，不是问题，是个服装穿帮。大家有没有注意到，凯文、德怀特和大卫·华莱士穿的衣服几乎一模一样？他们的角色性格大相径庭，但他们都穿着一件蓝绿色的衬衫，而且穿在每个人身上都非常合身。你知道吗，我当时没注意到这个，但我回去看了一眼，我还拍了张照片，非常好看。我完全同意。非常好看。确实很好看。
The color is lovely and it fits them all really well. And they are all wearing like this icy blue undershirt and then this sort of like dark gray suit. Oh yeah, they are. Kevin, Dwight and David Wallace. It's really lovely. You can put it in stories. Okay.
颜色很可爱，而且穿在他们每个人身上都非常合身。他们都穿着像这种冰蓝色的内衬打底衫，然后外面套着这种深灰色的西装。哦，确实是的。凯文、德怀特和大卫·华莱士。真的很好看。你可以发到快拍里。好吧。
Well, now we go to Andy's office because he's been totally set up by the Dunder Mifflin crew. And Wallace is talking to Andy and Andy says, "'Hey, so great about that balloon game "'that we got going on, especially in Wake of the Fire.'" Wallace is like, "'What are you talking about?' "'There's no fire in the warehouse.'"
好了，现在我们来到安迪的办公室，因为他被邓德米夫林的小伙伴们彻底整蛊了。华莱士正在和安迪说话，安迪说：“嘿，关于我们弄的那个气球游戏真是太棒了，特别是在那场火灾之后。”华莱士说：“你在说什么？仓库里根本没有火灾。”
I know, and then Andy's like, "'Oh, I mean, metaphorically. And he figures out what they were trying to do. Then later, Aaron's going to go into Andy's office and say, I don't love you anymore. You were gone a long time. You didn't email me very much. To be fair, you retweeted me quite a bit.
我知道，然后安迪就说：“哦，我是说，我是比喻。”然后他终于明白了他们到底想干什么。随后，艾琳走进安迪的办公室说，我不爱你了。你离开太久了。你都没怎么给我发邮件。公平地说，你转发了我好几次推文。
What is Aaron tweeting about? I don't know. Wouldn't you love to know? Yeah. We had fake Twitter accounts, remember? For a few characters. Yeah. Andy insists there's a lot of love between them. Aaron says there isn't any love on my side and he says you can just fake it. He's not letting her break up with him. Nope. Well, now we've got a pretty big scene. Jim is going to tell Pam they should cancel that bottle of wine and she should just drop them at the bus station.
艾琳到底在推特上发了什么？我不知道。你难道不想知道吗？对。我们有假的推特账号，记得吗？针对几个角色的。对。安迪坚称他们之间有很多爱。艾琳说我这边一点爱都没有了，而他说你可以假装有。他不让她甩了自己。不。好吧，现在有个相当大的场景。吉姆要告诉帕姆他们应该取消那瓶红酒，她只需要把他送到公交车站就行了。
Yeah. I'm sorry, do you want to see your children Jim? Thank you. You don't want to just like say hi to your kids. I know you don't want to go home and be a dad tonight. I mean yeah okay fine you and your wife are having a fight at least go hang with your kids. Sorry, had to do that rant. Does Jim
对。抱歉，你难道不想见见你的孩子们吗，吉姆？谢谢。你难道不想跟你的孩子们打个招呼吗？我知道你今晚不想回家当个爸爸。我是说，好吧，行吧，你和你老婆在吵架，至少去陪陪你的孩子吧。抱歉，我得发泄一下。吉姆
remember he has children? I don't know. I do feel like we needed to have more scenes of him just calling and like talking to the kids or something. The only time he does it is for Cece's dance recital when they're driving in the car. Yeah. He says he has work to do in Philly and she's probably got things to do as well and they'll probably just end up fighting anyway. And then he's like, oh, and here's a gift. I didn't have time to wrap it. Oh, I am so sorry, but I am gonna toot my own horn.
还记得他有孩子吗？我不知道。我确实觉得我们需要更多他只是打电话和孩子们聊天之类的场景。他唯一这么做的一次，是为了西西的舞蹈独奏会，当时他们正在车里开车。对。他说他在费城有工作要做，她大概也有事情要忙，而且他们最后可能也只会吵架。然后他就说，哦，对了，这是个礼物。我没时间包装了。哦，我很抱歉，但我得自吹自擂一下。
Okay. I love my reaction to the present. I love it when I'm like, oh, you kept it, thanks. Well, it's funny that you mentioned that because there was a note in the shooting draft about your reaction. What did it say? The whole scene was actually longer
好吧。我好喜欢我对礼物的反应。我好喜欢我当时说“哦，你居然留着它，谢谢”的那种状态。好吧，很高兴你提到这个，因为拍摄初稿里有一条关于你反应的备注。写的什么？整个场景其实更长，
and some of it's in deleted scenes. This is another thing I'm glad they cut out. Do you wanna hear it? Yes. Okay, Pam has just gotten the gift. The shooting draft says, Pam opens it. It's one of her drawings framed. It doesn't mean what it once would have,
有些被剪进删减片段了。这是另一个我很高兴他们剪掉的内容。你想听吗？想。好吧，帕姆刚收到礼物。拍摄初稿里写着：帕姆打开礼物。那是她的一幅被装裱起来的素描。这已经不是它曾经代表的意思了，
but she's still appreciative. That was my note. That was my acting note. Pam says, I didn't know you kept this, thank you. Jim says, no problem. Pam looks at Jim, he avoids her gaze. Then it cuts to a Pam talking head. Pam says, my husband Jim is very special and he's
但她还是很感激。那是我的备注。那是我的表演备注。帕姆说，我不知道你还留着这个，谢谢。吉姆说，没问题。帕姆看着吉姆，吉姆避开了她的目光。然后镜头切到一个帕姆的单人访谈。帕姆说，我的丈夫吉姆非常特别，而且他
stubborn and he's making me insane and he's impossible and I will not let him give up on me. Oh. And then it cuts back to the scene where she says, I think you should stay and fight. Pam won't let him give up on her? Excuse me? What the hell? You know, a lot of people wrote in to comment on this drawing, by the way. I'm going to read this one from Sarah S. in Montgomery, Alabama. Some people were confused about what is this drawing. Yeah.
很固执，他把我逼疯了，他不可理喻，但我绝不会让他就这样放弃我。哦。然后镜头切回场景，她对他说，我觉得你应该留下来抗争。帕姆不肯让他放弃她？对不起？搞什么鬼？你知道的，顺便说一句，很多人写信来评论这幅画。我要读一下来自阿拉巴马州蒙哥马利的莎拉·S.的信。有些人对这幅画到底是什么感到很困惑。对。
Well, Sarah said, I've been waiting forever for this. The gift that Jim gives Pam is a sketch from her sketchbook from when she returned from art school. And Jim had looked through the sketchbook and loved it, but it is a deleted scene. So Sarah says, this is the proof that deleted scenes are canon, that they do live in the
好吧，莎拉说，我等这个等了一辈子。吉姆送给帕姆的礼物是她从艺术学校回来时的速写本里的一幅素描。吉姆翻过这个速写本并且很喜欢它，但这其实是一个删减片段。所以莎拉说，这就证明了删减片段是正史，它们确实存在于
show. Sarah, wow. That kind of blows my mind. We also got this letter from Brittany T. in Dallas, Texas who said, I'm getting married in 2024 and my fiance and I have talked a lot about Jim and Pam's relationship throughout the show, specifically in season nine. Our many debates and conversations led to the same conclusion. I feel Jim had many dickish moments with Pam, like not telling her about Philly and not being very empathetic toward her being alone and scranton taking care of their family.
剧集中。莎拉，哇。这简直让我大开眼界。我们还收到了来自德克萨斯州达拉斯的布里塔尼·T.的信，她说，我将在2024年结婚，我和未婚夫在整部剧集里讨论过很多关于吉姆和帕姆的关系，特别是在第九季。我们的许多辩论和谈话都导向了同一个结论。我觉得吉姆对帕姆有过很多混蛋时刻，比如不告诉她去费城的事，对她独自留在斯克兰顿照顾家庭也没有表现出足够的同理心。
He feels Jim's attitude about Brian is justified and that he was just working hard for their family's future. The one thing we always admire is how intentionally they chose each other and how they really put in the work to improve their relationship. And as we are getting married soon and you are both happily married,
他觉得吉姆对布莱恩的态度是正当的，他只是在为他们一家的未来努力工作。我们一直以来最钦佩的一点是，他们是如何刻意地选择彼此，以及他们是如何真正付出努力来改善他们的关系的。随着我们即将结婚，而你们俩的婚姻也十分幸福，
we would love to hear your advice for overcoming rough patches and the secret to a long happy marriage. Well, Brittany, I am very happily married. This year is going to be our 14th wedding anniversary and a little over 16 years together. But I always like to fall back on some advice that I got from a woman who had been married over 40 years and it always stuck with me. So I thought I'd share that. Yeah.
我们很想听听你们对于度过感情低谷的建议以及长久幸福婚姻的秘诀。好吧，布里塔尼，我现在的婚姻非常幸福。今年将是我们的第14个结婚周年纪念日，我们在一起也已经16年多了。但我总是喜欢搬出我从一位结婚超过40年的女士那里得到的一条建议，它一直深深触动着我。所以我想把它分享出来。对。
I asked her the same question. I was like, 40 years, what's the secret? How'd you do it? Because I knew this couple and they were this lovely older couple. I had met them through church and they were so happy and wonderful together. And she said, well, I'll tell you the secret. I've been married to four different men. And I was like, What? She was like, Here's what you can count on. You can count on the fact that you all aren't going to change very much and that you're also going to change every 10 years. And I was like, Oh, tell me more. And she was like, About every 10 years in our marriage, we had a different season of our marriage. And I had to look at our season and look at this man,
我问过她同样的问题。我问，40年了，秘诀是什么？你们是怎么做到的？因为我认识这对夫妇，他们是一对非常可爱的老夫妻。我是通过教会认识他们的，他们在一起非常幸福美好。她说，好吧，我来告诉你秘诀。我嫁过四个不同的男人。当时我就想，什么？她说，以下是你可以确信的事。你可以确信的是，你们所有人其实都不会发生太大的改变，但你们每过10年也都会发生改变。当时我就想，哦，多讲讲吧。她说，在我们的婚姻中，大约每过10年，我们就会经历一段不同的婚姻时期。我不得不审视我们的时期，看着这个男人，
and I had to decide to commit to him again. And she said, and I've done that about once a decade. She said, because, you know, it's so easy in the beginning when it was just us before kids. And, you know, that's a whole season. And then, you know, then different jobs would come up and that stresses a person or changes a person. And she said, but I'll tell you what,
然后我必须决定再次对他做出承诺。她说，而且我大概每十年这样做一次。她说，因为，你知道的，一开始只有我们俩，在有了孩子之前，一切都那么容易，你知道，那是一整段时期。然后，你知道的，不同的工作会出现，这会给人带来压力或改变一个人。她说，但我告诉你，
if you pick right from the beginning, and you'll know if you're picking right, if you pick right from the beginning, then you'll be able to be married to all the versions of the person you're married to." She was like, you know, they say marriage is work and it really is, but it should also be the easiest work. She said, life is hard, your marriage should be easy.
如果你从一开始就选对了人，而且如果你选对了人，你就会知道的，如果你从一开始就选对了人，那么你就能够与你所嫁之人的所有不同阶段的版本都保持婚姻状态。”她还说，你知道，人们说婚姻是需要经营的，确实如此，但它也应该是最轻松的经营。她说，生活很难，你的婚姻应该轻松。
And I was like, wow, I really like that. I like that too. And this was a woman I met before I had ever married Lee. And then when I started dating Lee, I was like, oh, this is what she was talking about. Yeah. Well, you know, my mom always would say, in the course of a lifetime, romance comes and goes.
当时我就想，哇，我真的很喜欢这个观点。我也很喜欢。而且这是我在认识李之前遇到的一位女士。后来我开始和李约会时，我就想，哦，这不就是她以前说过的那样吗。好吧，你知道的，我妈妈总是说，在一生当中，浪漫总是来来去去。
So marry your best friend. And Josh is my best friend. And then, you know, on a lighthearted note, Brittany, I think a true test of any relationship is if you can go to Ikea we should fight." And he agrees. It just melts Jim's heart. It does. He smiles and says, all right, Beasley, put your dukes up. A lot of fans noted that Jim calls Pam Beasley at the end of this episode. And she loves it when he calls her Beasley. That's right. And this is, I think, how we know this
所以，嫁给你的最好朋友吧。乔什就是我的最好朋友。然后，你知道，说个轻松的话题，布里塔尼，我觉得任何关系的真正考验都是看你们能不能一起去宜家，我们该吵一架了。”而他答应了。这简直融化了吉姆的心。确实融化了。他微笑着说：“好吧，比斯利，摆好架势吧。”很多粉丝注意到吉姆在本集结尾叫了帕姆“比斯利”。而且她特别喜欢他叫她比斯利。没错。我想，这就是我们如何得知
is going to be okay. Well, Erin Erin is gonna find Pete in the parking lot. A lot happens in the parking lot in this episode. She apologizes that she couldn't break up with Andy and he says, hey, you know what? I just want you to be happy. And that melts her heart. And she gives him a big kiss. Well, we got this letter from Katherine P
一切都会好起来的。好吧，现在艾琳要在停车场找到皮特了。这集里停车场发生了好多事。她为自己没能跟安迪分手向他道歉，而他说，嘿，你知道吗？我只希望你快乐。这彻底融化了她的心。她给了他一个大大的吻。好吧，我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州雷丁的凯瑟琳·P.的信，
in Reading, Pennsylvania, who said this, just a quick story about why this episode means a lot to me. When I was in college, I started talking to this guy that I really liked. Suddenly his ex-girlfriend, who for the record had left him for another guy, suddenly resurfaced and wanted him back. He came to see me one night after having talked to his ex. I told him that while I obviously wanted to be with him, what I wanted more was for him to his ex. I told him that while I obviously wanted to be with him,
她是这么写的：讲一个小故事，关于为什么这一集对我有这么重大的意义。我上大学时，开始和这个我真的很喜欢的男生聊天。突然，他的前女友——顺便说一句，这个前女友曾经为了另一个男人抛弃了他——突然又出现并想要复合。有一天晚上，他在和前女友谈过后跑来见我。我告诉他，虽然我显然想和他在一起，但我更希望的是他能前女友。我告诉他，虽然我显然想和他在一起，
what I wanted more was for him to be happy. He gave me a big hug and said that his ex had listed all the reasons why she was the right choice, but never once told him to do what made him happy. It reminded me a lot of how Pete just wanted Erin to be happy. Thankfully, Pete and I both got our own happily ever after since I've been with that guy from college for the past 12 years and we've been married for seven.
我更希望的是他能够快乐。他给了我一个大大的吻，说他的前女友列举了所有她为什么才是正确选择的理由，但从头到尾没有一次叫他去做让自己快乐的事。这让我想起了皮特只想让艾琳快乐的那一幕。谢天谢地，我和皮特都迎来了我们自己的幸福结局，因为我和那个大学时期的男生已经在一起12年了，结婚也7年了。
Hey. Hey. Love that. Congratulations, Catherine. I love that story. Erin is now just going to kind of barge right into Andy's office and she's going to say, you know what? We're breaking up. I thought you were dead. You were gone for three months. She really just kind of bears her soul to him here in this moment. He's kind of speechless. And then she leaves.
嘿。嘿。太棒了。恭喜你，凯瑟琳。我好喜欢这个故事。现在艾琳径直闯进了安迪的办公室，说道，你知道吗？我们分手吧。我以为你死了呢。你离开足足三个月。她在这里真的向他敞开了心扉。他一时语塞。然后她就离开了。
Well, we find out that David Wallace was on speakerphone and heard everything. And he says, what's this about being gone for three months, Andy? And that's how the episode ends. Yes. Well, there you have it. That's couples discount. This episode is going to set up quite a few big storylines and I'm so excited for the next few episodes and we have some fantastic guests coming up.
好吧，我们发现大卫·华莱士当时正开着免提，把一切都听得清清楚楚。他说，安迪，这离开三个月是怎么回事？这一集就这样结束了。是的。好吧，这就是全部内容了。这就是“情侣折扣”。这一集为接下来的一些重大剧情做好了铺垫，我真的好期待接下来的几集，而且我们接下来还有一些非常棒的嘉宾要来。
We do. So thank you guys so much for rewatching and listening, for sending in your questions and comments. Thank you to Steve Burgess for his call sheets and all his good production behind the scenes trivia. And thanks to Jordan and Cassie for helping us out this week. And we hope you guys have a great one. We'll see you next week.
确实如此。非常感谢大家重温和收听，感谢大家发来问题和评论。感谢史蒂夫·伯吉斯提供通告单以及所有精彩的幕后制作花絮。感谢乔丹和卡西这周对我们的帮助。希望大家度过美好的一周。我们下周见。
-♪ Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fischer, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Jordan Duffy. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins, our audio engineer is Jordan Duffy, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
-♪ 感谢收听“办公室女士”。“Office Ladies”由 Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利联合制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是乔丹·达菲。“Office Ladies”由 Earwolf、詹娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯，音频工程师是乔丹·达菲，副制作人是艾恩斯利·布巴科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Rubber Tree》。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。